this is Jocko podcast number 204 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening
by virtue of the authority vested in me
as president of the United States and as
commander-in-chief of the armed forces
of the United States I have today
awarded the Presidential Unit Citation
for extraordinary heroism to the studies
and observations group military
assistance command the studies and
observation group is cited for
extraordinary heroism great combat
achievement and unwavering fidelity
while executing unheralded top-secret
missions deep behind enemy lines across
Southeast Asia incorporating volunteers
from all branches of the armed forces
and especially US Army Special Forces
SOGs ground air and sea units fought
efficiently denied actions which
contributed immeasurably to the American
war effort in Vietnam matvey SOG
reconnaissance teams composed of Special
Forces soldiers and indigenous personnel
penetrated the enemy's most dangerous
redoubts in the jungle Laotian
wilderness and the sanctuaries of
eastern Cambodia pursued by human
trackers and even bloodhounds these
small teams outmaneuvered out fought and
outran their numerically superior foe to
uncover key enemy facilities rescue down
pilots plant wire traps mines and
electronic sensors capture valuable
enemy prisoners ambush convoys discover
and assess targets for b-52 strikes and
inflict casualties all out of proportion
to their own losses when enemy
countermeasures became dangerously
effective SOG operators innovated their
own counters from high-altitude
parachuting and unusual explosive
devices to tactics as old as the French
and Indian War fighting alongside their
Mountain yard Chinese nung Cambodian and
Vietnamese allies
special forces LED Hatchett forces
companies and platoons staged daring
raids against key enemy facilities in
Laos and Cambodia / ran major munitions
and supplies stockpiles and blocked
enemy highways to choke off the flow of
supplies to South Vietnam SOGs
cross-border operations proved an
effective economy of force compelling
the the Vietnamese the North Vietnamese
Army to divert 50 thousand soldiers to
rear air D security details from far
from the battlefields of South Vietnam
supporting these hazardous missions were
SOGs own u.s. and South Vietnamese Air
Force transport and helicopter squadrons
along with US Air Force forward air
controllers and helicopter units of the
US Army and US Marine Corps these
courageous aviators often flew through
heavy fire to extract sog operators from
seemingly hopeless situations saving
lives by selflessly risking their own
SOGs Vietnamese naval surface forces
instructed and advised by US Navy SEALs
boldly raided North Vietnam's coast and
one surface victories against the North
Vietnamese Navy while indigenous agent
teams penetrated the very heartland of
North Vietnam
despite casualties that sometimes became
universal SOGs operators never wavered
but fought throughout the war with the
same flare fidelity and intrepidity that
distinguished SOG from its beginning the
studies and observations groups combat
prowess martial skills and
unacknowledged sacrifices saved many
American lives and provide a paragon for
America's future Special Operations
Forces signed the President of the
United States George Walker Bush
and that is the Presidential Unit
Citation presented for those that served
in Mac V SOG the studies and observation
group in Vietnam and for those of you
that don't know what the Presidential
Unit Citation is it's an award that is
given to whole units who and this is
this is the way they describe it I quote
display gallantry determination and
esprit de corps that sets them apart
from other units and you have heard
about SOG on this podcast before first
from John Stryker Meyer otherwise known
as tilt and he was on podcast 180 181
and 182 and then from his
comrade-in-arms the late great hero Doug
the Frenchman Letourneau and it is an
honor for us tonight to have another
sock warrior here Henry dick Thompson
code named dynamite and later known as
The Terminator who served as a SOG one
one and as a one zero and then continued
on with 21 years in the Army eventually
retiring and having a whole nother
career as a leadership consultant author
and speaker mr. Thompson and I know I
should probably say dr. Thompson because
I know you've got your PhD as well if
the in case everything else was enough
sir welcome to the program thank you for
coming on thank you for having me
looking forward to it so let's start at
the beginning on a little town called
Valhalla not far from Clemson University
and and what what years what you report
1947 1947 so you kind of grew up in the
50s yeah pretty
and and then were you were you at a
military family or anything like that my
father yeah my father was world war ii
and korea my mother had five brothers Oh
World War two one was killed so I was
around it you know white from the start
because I you know family was together a
lot so had a lot of discussion you know
about the war and things that were going
on and I was always asking questions and
how do you do this and how do you do
that and how do you organize so I was
interested you know right from the
beginning and your dad was in world war
ii and korea what was his job in the
military what branch was in infantry so
and he did work with the Rangers for a
while
and World War two hey would you hear him
would he deep brief you all the types of
operations that he did and war two in
Korea some of it he didn't talk a whole
lot about exactly what he did but he
would talk in general about what was
going on about the kinds of operations
and things so what theater did you fight
him he was in Germany most of the time
in that area so anyway how long was he
in the army for I I mean was about four
years and then he got out and then when
Korea came along then they called him
back in and that's really where I
started to hear about it because I was
old enough by then to hear people talk
about Korea and about the war and I
would you know he would write letters
home and talk about how deep the mud was
or how cold it was and things like that
so I was hearing about the war you know
firsthand and then so and were you
thinking I'm going in the military I was
probably four or five when I started
thinking about that and interestingly
enough I I did found find my old log
book because I also got interested in
the Rangers I wanted to
Ranger when I went in so I found a log
book that I created when you know I was
about nine or so when I created it I had
all the members of our Ranger company
listed which was primarily my cousins
but you know we had some other people
we've recruited in and we had the
journal a lot of things that we did
people who got promoted people who might
court-martial so were you guys doing
night raids and stuff and we spent a lot
of time in the woods I grew up in the
woods you know when I was five years old
when I get a chance I'd go off in woods
by myself I would go play attract
animals I'd listen to the sounds I'd
learn how to move by the time I was six
I had a army pup tent and I would take
up on top of the hill in the woods
put it up sleep up there by myself that
night take some eggs and stuff with me I
build a little fire you know cook as I
got a little older and had my BB gun
take out some birds roast them over the
fire so doing things like that that I
thought Rangers did you the the
six-year-old Ranger now company
commander getting after it
well the log books at general Thompson
that works and then what about high
school did you play sports football on
track how was your athletic capability I
was better than average on the team I
wasn't you know college material but you
know because I was relatively small but
I could hit really hard in my senior
year they even moved me from running
back to defensive in which I was on a
line that weighed over 200 pounds and I
was 140 you didn't want to come around
my in my other skill was you know it was
very fast so when the quarterback had
dropped back he'd see me in his face
because I could get there really quickly
and then sir when you graduated high
school did you did you know you were
going to college or what was your plan
yeah I started college and after about a
year and a half you know Vietnam was
going hot and heavy you saw it on the
news every night were year to graduate
high school 65 okay so yeah
I from what I can tell because I wasn't
alive then but from what I can tell the
the battle the I drank Valley was in
1965 and that was kind of where the real
hey we're we're in combat all the time
now it seems to have that seems to be
the pivot point that's noticeable when
you look at it historically well that's
that was when I think we discovered the
North Vietnamese had a real army mmm and
they were very good much better than
anybody thought at the time and over the
next few years I mean you you could
place them probably in the top four in
the world in terms of armies plus we
were fighting in their backyard they
knew the terrain they knew how to
operate deer they didn't stop they just
keep coming
their biggest disadvantage was they
didn't have the technology that we did
they didn't have air superiority and
just a lot of things they didn't have
that held them back or it would have
been much worse than it was
so it's 1965 is that's when you said you
graduated high school right and when you
graduate high school you go to college
where'd you go to college University
South Carolina and then you said it was
like a year and a half to do what you
end up doing well I I made a decision
that what I wanted to do is take a break
from school because Vietnam was going on
I felt an obligation you know to go do
something do my part and actually was on
my way to the Marine recruiter because
that's who you saw on TV every night but
stop by the army recruiter who was next
door just to see what they had to offer
so I went with the army and I knew that
would give me a chance to
do the Rangers if I decided that's what
I wanted to do by then I was also a
chemist about 13 I developed a passion
for chemistry so in addition to all the
outdoor stuff you know I was I set up my
own laboratory in the barn at home I
spent all my money on chemicals and I
know you like this but back in the day
back in the day you could go into a
pharmacy and buy all kinds of things I
mean you could buy you know nitric acid
you know I mean just unbelievable of
chemicals you know you could buy
particularly if you got your mother to
sign for you say yeah it's okay to let
him have that stuff and I would stock my
my lab with it and do all kinds of
experiments I I was getting close maybe
to a successful brain exchange between
birds and frogs I could get it in the
air I just couldn't get them you know to
start breathing again afterwards so I
have a lot of that sounds close yeah
yeah anyway so were you studying
chemistry in college yes
yeah I went to school on a chemist a
scholarship the intent was to be you
know get a doctorate in chemistry and be
a researcher but then I decided to take
the break do three years in the army and
then come back and finish the degree
so it so is it 1967 now one in 67 so
it's 1967 how strong was were the
sentiments in America against the war
years know in 67 very stone so that was
already there yeah what about in South
Carolina oh not as much as some of the
other parts of the country you know but
it was still there it wasn't something
that everyone thought we should be doing
mm-hmm and what about your dad who had
seen combat in World War two and in
Korea how did he feel about going he
supported it my mother doesn't you know
she wanted anything just go on
I'm just taking a three-year but I'll
come back and finish the doctorate and
everything he'll be fine she said no you
want so what I'll be back unfortunately
when I got in they started talking about
man you got to go to everyone school you
need to be airborne and they said you
need to go to sea yes yeah you need to
be an officer so at what point so you go
to boot camp right and is it boot camp
where they're like looking at you going
hey we need airborne soldiers yeah there
was at a pretty easy pathway to get to I
yes it was I mean they they ask you day
one when you go into an induction Center
you don't want volunteer to be airborne
my response was no that's not what I'm
here for it but then once I got into you
know boot camp
I ate that stuff up did you still so
when you were when you when you went in
what was the predominant part of your
brain that was functioning was it hey
I'm gonna do three years serve my
country and looked for a job that'll be
similar to being a chemist or was the
primary part of your brain that was
functioning was the I wanted to be a
ranger and and go get after it it was
when I first entered first couple of
days it was you know three years I'm out
go back to school be a chemist I guess
it was maybe the first morning we were
in the barracks and you know about 3:30
or 4 o'clock the lights come on somebody
started yelling and screaming and
hollering to get out of the out of bed
fall in you know get in the formation in
front of the box and then I hear you
know when double box I hear him start
crashing onto the floor then I jump out
and I look and here's this guy smaller
than me and he was big you know smokey
the bear had on a Ranger tab
Wow and everybody there jumped one night
guy said to do you something I said okay
I need to start rethinking here there's
gotta be something innate in men to do
that just that's just what happens you
see that you go guess I'm in for that
yeah I mean this guy was impressive and
you know that brought back all the
ranger stuff and it started to override
the chemistry you know so then then we
get out we were on the firing range you
know and I was an expert marksman before
ever you know went in so I'd max out two
marks in the show and you know good
physical condition so everything they
were doing I could do and I learned it
really fast one night I was on CQ duty I
had to work in the orderly room but the
person who was there all night and I saw
this book laying on the table
I was fpm 22 - 100 drill and ceremonies
and I picked it up and I started looking
at it and I thought this tells you
everything about you know right face
left face when to call the command all
this I said it's all written out right
here I mean if I had this book the last
couple of weeks so I read the book that
night no I read pretty fast the next day
I could see the mistakes that the drill
sergeants are making and I made the
mistake one time while pointing it out
so you know I get to work on my triceps
and packs a little bit as I pushed push
for it going a little bit closer then
China but um my family just self was
already down you can give me access to
it I'll learn it and so I was the put in
charge of my patent as a platoon guide
because you know physically mentally
everything I was doing great I had a
good time and then you volunteer was it
did you have a job designated when you
went in where you were you're gonna be
infantry when you went in there I was
going into chemical
so oh so the chemistry brain was
legitimately winning when you went in
that was for a few days and then and
then did you change your your specialty
to infantry yeah you walked in and said
yeah hey I know I showed up to be a
chemist but I want to carry a machine
gun maybe how hard was it to do that not
hard at all because I was so fired up I
love the things that we were doing and I
figured I can do this for three years
and I can still go back and do be a
chemist if I want to but they let you
change they let you study said okay cool
hey if you want to change the infantry
during that time there was no problem no
problem anybody that would volunteer for
that I mean you got it right away
and then next up how did you volunteer
for Airborne School same thing yeah I
mean I just had an opportunity to
volunteer
well after boot camp you go to in my
case I want the advanced infantry
training AI so yeah so you you know in
there you're volunteering for different
things so I volunteered you know for OCS
I volunteered to go to Airborne School
so I went to OCS first and they sent you
to OCS even though you hadn't completed
college yes and they didn't care not at
that time they're like hey you're smart
lieutenants were getting killed so fast
I mean they couldn't produce lieutenants
fast enough I you know lieutenant had a
life expectancy of about a day and a
half in Vietnam so you know that was
easy to get in and you know I did that I
did you know really well and I would say
yes so it was easy when I said okay I
want to go to Airborne School and I want
to go Special Forces so you made that
decision as well yeah now what about
being going from officers to Special
Forces was there any challenge and
making that happen or was it still just
open wide open they took me right in
yeah okay you know I done well I I got
accepted to that you know so I had to
know he had to go sport 1920 so you're
19 years old you have a year and a half
of college you're an officer in the army
going to special forces airborne and
this is all distracting you to go to
Vietnam yeah and you're on that track
place I'm gonna go ahead well it's gonna
say when you so airborne school you know
is airborne school I went to everyone
scores lucky lucky enough to have been
in the Navy when we still went to Fort
Benning Georgia and an Airborne School
but what about Special Forces school as
you were going through that what was
your impression of what was going on
what was the instruction like how well
was that preparing you from your
perspective for what we were going to be
doing in Vietnam I think it did a it
didn't prepare me for SOG necessarily it
gave me a lot of the basics Special
Forces is not just about going in and
conducting a raid or something like that
it's really about going in and working
with the people we did a lot of training
on insurgencies our governments are
overthrown different things like that so
particularly since I was an officer I
was on the officer track so we were
doing a lot of the bigger picture staff
plus officers get trained and all of the
primary skill sets of Special Forces
whereas if you're enlisted coming coming
out of the qualification training you go
to be a weapon specialist there to be a
medic or whatever you go into a
specialty area officers have to be
trained in all of them so that you
understand what the people are talking
about if you're going to lead them so I
enjoyed that did well in it volunteered
for Ranger School then you went to
Ranger School after went to Ranger
School after so a lot of harassment and
my Ranger buddy and I you know we've
been together forever
so we go there it was that Bob yeah that
was Bob and we have to you have to go
knock on the door to get in to report in
to Ranger School and you can't knock on
the door hard enough so Bob and I got
back and ran into it and just knocked it
off
and then reported in you know the
instructors that's there he looked to us
he looked down to the paper and he told
the other guy that was with him he said
we've got to snake eaters here we're
gonna have to keep an eye on him to make
sure they don't crap in the street out
there or something you know it went
downhill from there because then it
became Ranger school kind of became a
tug of war between yourself and and the
Rangers so every time you did something
if they dropped you for push-ups I mean
you then you had to do one more for the
big Ranger in the sky so Bob and I would
do for the big Ranger in the sky and too
for the big SF trooper looks over the
big ranger you know then they put it
back down again so you know it we tried
to have as much fun in Ranger school as
we could
yeah that's it it was tough and being
able to put a little humor in it as you
went along now was Ranger School in
terms of preparation for what you're
gonna be doing in SOG a little bit
closer yes because now you're doing
light infantry Wow
it's it's really infantry but it's
patrolling operations raid ambushes you
know those kinds of things that we're
doing in SOG in fact you know when I
first got to SOG when I went in with
with my group everybody that I arrived
with went to what they called a 1-0
school the SOG team leader school and
I'm standing there and everybody else is
walking away as what about me and you
don't need to go to 1-0 school you're a
ranger you're going to a team tomorrow
you'll be on a team so what point did
you hear about SOG you heard rumors you
know when you s F at Fort Bragg every
once in a while somebody would mentioned
the term SOG and you'd what is that what
do they get home and stop secret you
know nobody can tell you what it is but
they really do some really cool missions
I mean that's the elite but but nobody
can tell you what
really do so so you you Hamlet this all
the schooling must have taken what two
years for you to get through all the
schooling year-and-a-half at this point
probably year and a half and when you
get done with Ranger School
you finally check into a Special Forces
Group no I don't really we were in there
was a little in earlier before Ranger
school so we were already assigned to an
a-team Toby team
I was already targeted toward Africa and
actually in mission preparation to
deploy to Africa for a mission that
we're going on there but I had
volunteered to I had put in the
paperwork to go to Vietnam so right
after Ranger school that came through
and you went to all these schools with
your friend Bob yeah how did you know
him where did you guys meet we met and
advanced infantry training right off the
bat so I mean it was it was unreal we
just every school we had the same
interest so I mean we went to every
school together you know the whole time
where was he from California okay but
you guys just hit it off yeah you guys
were both had the same boy head that
same mindset we're gonna do it
so then what so so you get your orders
changed and was that hard to do again I
mean hey if there's if there's a choice
in the military if there's a tourist
between sending someone to Africa or
sending them to Vietnam at that time
Vietnam was going to win it'll always
want out so as long as you wanted to
take the hardest jobs and do the
toughest things there's pretty easy to
go that path will end up for ya the army
will accommodate you yeah
so all right let's get let's head over
to Vietnam when you show up there I
remember tilt saying they kind of showed
up in Vietnam and they said hey who
wants to volunteer now for SOG is that
what happened to you did you already
volunteer knew no or you were going I
knew is going to special forces I knew
it give a Special Forces assignment and
then when when we got there
there was a guy who was already there
working in a Mike force but he was there
in the train and so we linked up with
him we went to a bar that night and you
know he kind of updated us on things
that were going on and one of the things
he said was I'm tomorrow toward the end
of the day one of the last things
they're going to do is they're gonna ask
you if you wanted to volunteer for SOG
and he said whatever you do don't do it
just tell them no they'll say thank you
and you know you move on to your special
forces assignment so the next day
towards the end of the day where Bob and
I are sitting in the office waiting to
go in to see Colonel Jones or whatever
and he said what are you gonna do and I
said I'll make my decision you have to
make yours yeah this is not a joint
decision on this thing you know so I
went in and he asked me about SOG told
me just a little bit and then said you
know if you want to do that you have to
sign a bunch of papers here you
volunteering for six months basically go
anywhere to do anything and you said you
got to understand I'm saying anything
okay and then you know you have to sign
this other thing you can't tell anybody
for 20 years
you know what you do stuff like that so
I volunteered he sent me out the back
door
and brought Bob in the other door I went
back over until the little bar to meet
up with her friend and I came walking in
he said you did it I can see it on your
face said you are a dead man walking I
told you not to do that and you know
when Bob showed up it was the same way
you could say I knew he's gonna do it
but yeah so now you too so that that was
the attitude was the casualty rate was
so high in SOG that when someone
volunteered for it it was like they were
a dead man walking
I mean the chances of survival if you
ended up on a team if you want to you
know a staff position that's a little
different but if you were on a team you
new men are you gonna get wounded did
you and did you you knew that obviously
somebody is this what the guy that was
telling you don't don't go to SOG he
said don't go to saw because you're
gonna get wounded or you're gonna get
killed
there's guaranteed most likely you're
gonna get killed he said there's the
highest casualty rate in Vietnam is
there those guys don't survive I'm not
sure exactly what they do but they don't
survive you got something you got one
note in the notes you gave me it just
says blackbirds so we had to fly from
the train to des nein the next day
because if you're going to SOG began you
had to go to de name so when we go to
the airfield they take us to a
restricted area of the airfield and the
the c-130s and 123's that came into that
part of the airfield were black he said
well that's that's a little different
than everything else
and you get on on the aircraft and there
are no seats there seat belts on the
floor so the plane is gutted except for
the front end and there's a line up
there that says do not go beyond this
line classified area so something was
happening in the front of those planes
that we were not allowed to to go see so
we sat on the floor and you know we fly
up there and we get off escort picks us
out and he says there'll be a bus here
to pick you up in a few minutes to take
you or to CCU and so there's school bus
like thing shows up that's black the
windows are shot out they must have been
200 bullet holes in the bus and you know
we're looking at the bus thinking oh
geez why did we gotten into the guy
driving the bus he said we'll leave
in a few minutes we're picking up a team
here today - and I what happened to the
bus and he said well there's a pass that
we have to go through and we get
ambushed there sometimes so the main
thing for you you to to remember is if
you know the stuff starts you get on the
floor of the bus and do whatever the
team tells you they'll take care of
everything you just do what they tell
you if you want to live and we think man
that's not looking good we might not
even get there so but we did and we got
there what was it did you guys pick up a
team I know when we first got there you
know it was late afternoon they assigned
us to a bunk and told us that we would
get briefed the next morning and what we
were gonna do and told us this yeah
we've got something eating a mouse all
relaxed there'd be a movie showing that
night and or thing I'm gonna leave so
that they had constructed some kind of
like bleachers that in this little open
area held up a few sheets of plywood and
had a movie projector and they would get
movies from somewhere and they would
show a movie out there so we went let's
go watch the movie and behind that
screen was a marble mountain which juts
up out of the sand 450 feet just out of
nowhere this thing is jutting up there
and there's two peaks each peak up there
has a combat outpost on it because it's
the bad guys you know got up there they
could shoot right down into the compound
so we're watching the movie and all of a
sudden red and green tracers are going
here I mean it's just crisscross and
popping I'm starting to hit the ground
and everybody else just watching the
movie okay last one guys what's going on
he's don't worry about that happens
every night he said every night thank
God to get the guys off to combat
outposts and you know we put on a little
light show up there it'll be fine
they won't they don't shoot down here
because they getting shot at and they
shoot back at those people
Wow that's so so then what happens you
when everyone else got sent to 1-0
school did Bob get sent to 1-0 school or
is he the same as you well before before
they the next morning we got our
briefing we went into the to the
headquarters into the briefing room and
you know the colonel came in and said
okay let me let me tell you what sock is
about let me tell you what you're going
to be doing and he uncovered some maps
on the wall and started talking about
the kinds of missions that we would be
going on and you know we would be put on
teams and we'd be leading those missions
and he kind of explained that you know
we had three major areas he had the
northern area which was ceasing in there
but the forward operational base was up
in Phu Bai and so he explained where the
the different camps were and then after
that he you know he told me I'd be going
to lob one up north Bob would be going
down to central down around Kahn - you
know so we went our different ways at
that point did uh when he started brief
you on what the missions consisted of
did you did you have any was your guests
anywhere close to that did you do you
have any idea and say yeah that's
probably what I thought we would be
doing was it close I had heard rumors
that maybe they operated outside of the
Vietnam you know so they didn't surprise
me that much when he started talking
about the countries we're going to
actually go into the kinds of missions
didn't surprise me too much I mean a few
of them did but for the most part it was
wow this is pretty cool that's crazy but
he's pretty cool did he talk to you at
all about casualty rates or anything no
no all right so so then what happens you
get a sign yeah so I want to fop Wynette
Phu by with a group of other people and
we got
here they grab the everybody but me and
said you know you guys are going to 1-0
school so a week-long course to teach
them how to be a leader small team in
the jungle there are a few things that
they've probably got that I hadn't done
already but not much so I was assigned
are told I'd be assigned a team the next
morning told me to go report over to the
supply room they had a mission for me
first that I needed to do so when I got
there they told me that we had had some
casualties and that their personal
effects had to be inventoried you know
by an officer before they could be sent
home so he said you know their duffel
bags are in there you know if you just
dump them out go through them and look
for anything that might be classified a
map or anything like that if there's any
correspondence in there read it
make sure it doesn't say anything about
any of the missions if there are
pictures you know get all the pictures
out so pretty well you know sterilizer
their gear so the first bag I picked up
when I read the name I thought well you
know I know him so this is a guy that
you know we had run around with some at
Bragg's already in Ewing and he came
over and you know about a month before
me and now I'm into his stuff so I kind
of got my attention at the casualty rate
you know probably was pretty high here
but then the next day I was you know a
scientist as one one assistant team
leader and you know we started mission
prep to get ready to go out but who was
the team leader sergeant deck so it's
very cool that even though you were an
officer you were gonna be a
second-in-command no one no one was
gonna walk into a team regardless of you
rank and just you know say I'm here and
I'm
the team leader you had regardless of
you rank you had to go out as an
assistant or or lower and learn how to
lead a team learn what's going on out
there and eventually get checked off by
the team leader he would you know like
sergeant deck had to say okay
Thompson can lead a team now that put me
put me on the list to take over the next
team you know that was available so what
did the team consists of myself and you
know I mean sergeant deck myself and
another American and then you know we
had probably nine indigenous members on
the team and who were the first ended
what kind of ended crimes the first
screw where they Vietnamese really
Vietnamese and then did you or did you
go through any training protocol to be
ready for your first mission or what
will change do I mean they'll just we've
started training right away once I was a
sign you know deck grabbed me up and
started talking to me this is what you
got to do here's what I'm looking for
here's where we're going what we're
going to do we took the team out we
started doing immediate action drills
and in preparation for what we were
going to do on the mission how long did
you guys have the train before you guys
warm out on your first mission I it was
it was probably eight to ten days before
we actually went out so I had a little
time to get to know the team better to
learn all the the drills and the way
they did things what was the level of
English speaking for your industry not
very good for the interpreter and the
others they understood some words you
know the common words that you would use
get down stop you know things like that
that you used all the time but I mean
that you couldn't carry on the
conversation and what was your how good
was your level of focus during this time
I imagine you must have been just as
focused as a human being could get I
mean this is real
I saw totally focus nothing else oh my
in fact we had a we had a little Theatre
in the air at Phu Bai had a little top
on it so if it rained we didn't get wet
but some old benches we were sailing on
a piece of plywood the movie was on I'm
sorry I went to a movie after a couple
days they had one I went to the movie
that even I'm sitting here and I hear
this loud pal when the guy next to me
falls off on the ground I'm thinking
yeah because we're sitting outside we
just have a little top-off and he falls
over on the ground getting the shoulder
Wow didn't matter where you are that
puts a downer on ya I wasn't that much
in the movie all right so now what's the
first mission that you guys get assigned
I'm they were doing some testing who
among other things then in addition to
just sending his own admission they were
trying to figure out what was the best
time to put a team on the ground should
you put them in right at first light so
when you get off the aircraft you can
move out and head to wherever you're
going to go you you're getting away from
the LZ quickly you know because they the
bad guys that figure out G of being
inserted nice to come out and start
looking for you
Orin was the best way to do it go in at
last light so it's dark you get off the
LZ you set up and you're remain
overnight position and then head out at
first light
so the NVA or tractors are coming after
you then they were having to do it in
the dark so our team had been selected
to be a last light insertion to see how
that worked so you know and I had
already been briefed on some things like
we go in high we go in 3,000 feet or so
when we're flying to the LZ to aboard
the small orange fire coming up at us
and then when you get out there to the
nativity LZ he's going to Bank the
aircraft on the side
and he's gonna put it in auto-rotate and
it's just gonna fall out of the sky in a
spiral until he gets to where he wants
to make his short final coming into the
LZ and then you'll put the power back on
and slow it down and we'll come in I was
not quite prepared for that I mean I I
understood the concept what he was
saying but I didn't realize that when he
put that thing in auto-rotate I wasn't
gonna be sitting on anything and then I
was on the side that it was turned
toward so I'm just hanging out the air
in the air holding onto the side of the
aircraft looking down 3,000 feet and
saying this is not good you know my
stomach's up in my throat and it's like
a thrill ride at the fair or something
and this thing that's appalling and I'm
I'm just trying to hang on and stay in
there so we spiral into em we come
around and coming in on a short final
it's on the ridge line and they had
dropped it was called a daisy cutter
2000 pound bomb to blow a hole in the
canopy big enough that we could set the
helicopter down and we're coming in
we're flying over a little pond on the
ridgeline and I'm you know climbing out
on the skid of the helicopter myself and
the other American the team leaders on
the other side thought we're climbing
out on the skid and I'm thinking man I
mean we're going really slow and I'm
just a sitting target I mean they could
just knock me off of this thing any time
that's a night not good so we come up
and we had to literally go straight down
into the bomb crater so the pilots
trying not to clip trees as we're
setting down is just getting dark and
we're going in and myself and the other
guy or on the skid and we're close
enough and he slowed down enough I said
okay this is it we're gonna have to jump
on
you know down into the bomb crater I
bent my knees to jump and just as I did
I saw that as god pop up on my right by
10 feet you know coming off to the side
with an ak-47 and just instantly instead
of jumping I push back jump back up on
the edge as I look out there just as I
jump up you know he opens up with the a
K and then the bullets come right across
where my legs were but now I've moved
and they hit you know the other American
on the other side of me hit him in the
legs so he starts to fall so I'm
grabbing the back of his harness with my
left hand and I put a half a magazine in
the guy you know that's like there I
hold him down and I managed to jerk you
know the the other guy up onto the floor
of the helicopter and then I could turn
and put it you know I can just see
muzzle flashes right in front of me so I
put the other half of the magazine there
so now an empty you know and when when
we go in when you go in you would have
gunships who would come in alongside you
so in case something happens so we're in
a full-fledged ambush now all the way
around us to cope or gunships open up
with their many guns 4,000 rounds a
minute coming in looking like two hose
pipes just spraying red water all around
us and what you know a lot of people
don't realize is bullets don't just hit
the ground and going to ground the
ricochet they bounced all over the place
and if there are trees there they're
giving trees they're going around so I'm
trying to pull him I'm trying to pull
him back up inside the helicopter got
the door gunner on my side full blast
the the Cobras coming in and they're
also shooting forty millimeter grenades
at 250 a minute so we've got that going
on I got two team members behind me
using me for cover so I've got a muzzle
on each side of my head right here I'm
getting powder burns and you know from
the muzzle flashes coming out of there
I got hot brass coming from them coming
from the door gunner who went all over
means the floor is now covered with
blood blood squirting out of his legs
and and I my magazine is empty so I'm
trying to get the magazine out of my my
pants that had guided him and you know
one of the things I talk about and you
know was the stress book is that when
your stress level gets really high you
lose your fine motor coordination things
that you can do very easily when you're
not stressed just don't work for you
anymore so I'm trying I'm having trouble
getting the magazine out of the pouch to
start with I finally get it out and then
I can't get it in the weapon and I'm I'm
sitting there and I'm just seeing
hundreds and hundreds of bullets and
tracers coming green tracers
criss-crossing inside the aircraft so
hearing tracers criss-crossing
inside the aircraft there she just
explained to everybody that doesn't know
what that means
that's insane that means that enemy
bullets in Vietnam the the Americans and
used red tracers and the enemy used
green tracers and unfortunately it's not
really like that anymore
everybody uses red tracers and and I
that was what was like for us and in
Iraq and I had some guys hit me up and
said it's the same thing to have to
understand very rarely would they see
green tracers but for enemy tracers to
be criss-crossing inside of your
helicopter and this is a Huey right yeah
this is not a small this is this is not
a big aircraft this is a tiny aircraft
you're hacked in there so four rounds to
be criss-crossing
inside that thing green tracers that is
completely insane I was thinking that
myself it's a little voice in the back
of my head is saying yeah you know this
is crazy
not only that but I am NOT happy I mean
this is my first mission and I'm gonna
die on my first I mean you know what
kind of deal is this I came over here to
do something so that little voice is
going on back there and the other one
this is this is like 15 seconds into
your first mission yeah I mean it's
right there ricochets going all over the
place from
from the the covers and things and you
know I the other guy is rolling around
screaming holding his leg and you know
the blood squirting around and you're
also hearing this metallic clang just
clang clang with the bullets hitting the
helicopter and you know you you're
thinking to if this thing is going to go
down we're going to end up in this bomb
crater right there so all of that's
going on I finally managed to get the
other magazine you know in so then I can
start to shoot at you know the muzzle
flashes that I'm seeing and you know the
second time I go to reload I was a
little better with that one got it in
there a little faster the aircraft
starting to really vibe right now
because he's trying to lift up you know
out of that little hole in the canopy so
I'm thinking at least we're trying to
start up but this stuff is still coming
it's still hitting us and you've got to
you know covers making more raids and
now what's also happening I can't really
see it but the a1e Skyraiders that are
out there on station with us they give
us some protection they're starting to
drop 500-pound bombs just a little ways
from us
because those little dance crew Hut's
that I saw out there as we were
spiraling in turned out to have tanks
underneath them so they had just put
that stuff around and make them look
like a you know a little hoots but
really it was tanks that when the tank
started moving you know the sky Raiders
went after them and so you got all the
bombing and strafing of those guys going
on
you got the gunships hitting all
sheeting all around us we're trying to
come out and eventually we managed to
get up out of that hole the fire just
shifted now the tracers going up but as
we pulled away from it then you know
that fire stopped because now the Cobras
really opened up you know on the ambush
site
and I look across at sergeant deck
setting over on the other side and he
looks at me with a big grin on his face
and giving me a thumbs up I don't think
Oh what's wrong with this guy
so I mean he was so excited I mean he
thought that was the coolest thing and
I'm saying I mean almost died
this was my my first time I experienced
a level of fear that I didn't know
existed I mean I tried to imagine a lot
about you know what's it like you know
when people start shooting at you know
of course she's gonna be a little
anxious so what is it gonna be I had no
clue I couldn't even imagine a level of
fear like that but you know fortunately
I was able to control that part of the
fee I could still shoot it didn't stop
me from returning fire and doing what I
needed to do but yeah it scared me
having noticed two weapons right next in
my head I mean my high-frequency hearing
was steadily going away permanently
getting burned you know with with the
muzzle flashes coming out of there
killed my first two people for sure the
guy down below and the first guy shot
that it's in the tree because I saw him
come out I know I took those two out and
I hit several others saved the first
Americans life because if he had fallen
in the crater it had been gone a second
later and we'd have both jumped in that
crater and we were both being gone
that's bad tactics on their part right
they should have held for another two
seconds they should have had a ground I
would have been seven able to possibly
damage the helicopter and yeah yeah so
you know earn my combat infantryman's
badge yeah you did I had a had a whole
series of first that occurred right here
and you know survived that and you know
a couple of minutes later I'm thinking
man we got out of that and I looked down
and here comes a stream of tracers
coming up out of a 51 caliber or
something they were trying to hit the
helicopter they were you know ways
farmers but still I think it's not over
yet I mean we got to get out of here and
get back and I told
the door gunner I said you know we got
to go straight to the hospital you know
we got to drop this guy off he's got to
have a medical attention right away yeah
so we did that we dropped him off then
we went back to the launch site to drop
the team off but then I asked sergeant
deck I said um I'm just curious how many
magazines did you fire when we were back
there and he said I emptied five I had
had the six put in I was getting ready
to start on that through two
fragmentation grenades and a smoke
grenade and and then he said lieutenant
you need to practice so you get faster
reloading when people are shooting at
you are you gonna die that's it okay
I'll practice yeah because when you talk
about the fine motor skills disappearing
but if you practice them all the time
you'll be able to maintain them to some
degree yes there won't be as good but
they'll be better yeah you know and
that's part of the problem with training
you you train you train to get a good
sight picture sight alignment and all
that and you squeeze the trigger and hit
your your target that's not cheating
back out yes and then you know you get
in a firefight like that and your stress
level skyrockets and when it does you
can't see the sights on a weapon I mean
you trained to use those sights and now
let's say you your vision changes as the
stress goes up you can't focus on the
sights so you can't you can't do it to
what you trained you can't reload the
way you train you trained to turn
sideways and shoot and all of a sudden
when all the steps is coming at you your
body your brain takes over and says face
the enemy then you just got your body's
going to turn you toward the enemy so
you got a trained cheetah at the enemy
you got a trained to shoot without
aiming so to speak now I had been
through a pretty extensive course on
something that we call quick kill where
we train to shoot from the hill and we
started with BB guns and shot it a
little
Tirra silhouettes on a two-by-four
shooting from the hilt with a BB gun
until you could knock them all down and
then we started throwing discs up in you
know three inch discs up in the air and
you shoot with a BB gun too you could
hit that moving disk and then the disk
would get smaller and smaller and then
we would go on to a course where the
targets popped up and it is live fire in
terms of you know you're using your
weapon and shoot from the hill and get
so you can hit all the targets so we
practiced a lot and with the teams that
I had I just drilled it in their head
you've got to be able to shoot without
aiming you don't have time to bring up
and try to look through a sight it's
happening too fast you'll be dead before
you can get it up there so there are a
lot of techniques that I had brought in
that I had learned before I got there
and then you know kind of developed
across time and always trained the teams
do this do it like this that's quick one
of the NCOs had told me one night at
fubar he said you can't hesitate there's
no hesitation you got to understand
lieutenant where you're going everybody
is the enemy you don't have to worry
about shooting a friendly by mistake
they're all enemy and the person that
Chiefs first has the highest probability
of surviving pull the trigger and never
ever shoot anybody less than three or
four times and if he still moves you
shoot in three or four more times
there's no one shot and moved to the
next guy you make sure they go down you
know so that was kind of a strategy I
adopted and practiced to be able to do
that and I can I can go from the safety
position on the selector switch it's a
fully automatic faster than most people
can pull the trigger with with the
safety already off I used to practice
that I used to practice it going down I
also discovered that without ak-47 as
soon as they start to shoot after you
the barrel Rises if they don't hit you
for that first or second round
if you can get down you got a chance to
survive and I used to practice shooting
on the way down
put silhouettes out hit them all before
I hit the ground as I'm going down I
didn't see that magazine so kind of
getting off track you know that's that's
actually right on track the so you come
back from this first mission what was
your what what are you thinking now you
got to be thinking yourself there's no
possible way I'm living through this
well actually the way my mind works
I was critiquing what should we have
done what should we have trained on
beforehand what did we do there were we
prepared for an ambush like that was
there anything else we we could have
done so I was playing you know through
our preparation play in my and online
through what we actually did what could
we do differently next time
so in my mind you got to get better
every time every time you do something
you need to be better than the last time
that you did it you need to understand
it's gonna you're gonna always have to
adapt whatever you plan you're gonna
have to adapt and you know war is just
it's not predictable is the
predictability is that it's gonna change
yeah you know and you got to be able to
do that and do it on the fly yeah that I
had I was telling you I had just had a
guy on the podcast hasn't come out yet
but I had a guy that was he went in to
go he's a Marine he went in the
Guadalcanal Tarawa Saipan and Tinian got
wounded and taro got shot while he was
still 500 meters from the beach trying
to get across that that he'll that they
were walking through but you know we had
that discussion around you know always
thinking it's like nothing will happen
to me and I was used the example of like
I always think if if I'm on a commercial
airplane and it crashes I'm gonna live
like I'm gonna figure out a way and I'll
do a good freefall position and I'll
look scan and find a pool somewhere or
whatever was there it was there any of
that because it seems to me like that
kind of operation right there you got to
look at that and say even if even if you
have the attitude of it'll happen to
someone else when you've got green
tracer coming through your
craft that might change even my mind and
start thinking okay probably not going
to probably not going to make it through
this yeah you think that and I've had
I've used up more lives than a than a
cat you're just hearing that time period
used up nine lives that night I never
thought that I would those two minutes
I never thought I'd see my 21st or 22nd
birthday started no way you just can't
get there okay you know you you got to a
point where you said okay I'm probably
not gonna make it yeah but my attitude
is I'm gonna take as many of you with me
as I can you might get me but you're
gonna pay for it I'll be really upset if
you knock me off with the first round
and I don't get a chance to get some of
you but you better you better do it
quick because I want to take as many as
I can with me because I'm coming mm-hmm
okay so you guys get back from the from
that mission you guys do a good debrief
you're going through all the points of
what you thought you could do better
you're wondering who is who was the
person that came up with the idea of
doing these night inserts and maybe if
the last light inserts aren't the best I
don't know because that's another thing
you don't really know yeah you know it
seems to me like if you drop a daisy
cutter' and the enemy at least goes says
themselves well they drop the daisy
cutter' they must have done that for a
reason let's go surround it I mean why
would you drop a 2,000 pound one two
thousand pound bomb here on a Ridgeline
yeah and not doing anything else unless
you're coming yeah well is she gonna
come please drop 15 of them to give to
make the enemy have to spread out a
little bit not put their entire force
surrounded this one crater yeah there
are a lot of things like that I thought
about you know once he got back you know
I was making a list
[Music]
unfortunately I shared some of my list
with the commander of the camp he was
excited and telling me I told you we
could get you out you know we put you
out there we're gonna get you out
at work right and I say I saw I think we
share some thoughts with you uh
unfortunately I probably had talked to
mr. Jack Daniels two months before I had
that conversation and I shared a little
too much of my thoughts he wasn't
exactly you know happy some of the
things I had to say because it reflected
on him too I still think they're right
you know you put ones like you said you
put one day's gutter out here you know
why don't we put up a flag for everybody
coming here soon you know all right sir
then what's the next mission looking
like oh I see then I think the next one
the next one we actually had to spend
the night so we did a lot a lot of
planning and at this point you know
sergeant deck starting to listen you
know I've got more credibility now I've
been shot at and you know we did okay so
we we put a lot more planning into it a
lot more rehearsal into it and went in
got on the ground
uneventful and when you would get on the
ground you would you to move 100 meters
or so into the jungle you would stop set
up a security perimeter and then you
adapt you listen do you hear any bad
guys what do you hear you got to adapt
to the sounds of the jungle first
because the last 45 minutes an hour all
you've heard it says wah wah wah for the
helicopter and you know so you've had a
temporary threshold shift in you here
and you can't hear as good you can't
smell is good because you've been
smelling the jp4 and the helicopter all
the way out there
so you have that security halt and you
adapt to the sounds what's out here
what are you here what do you see in my
case I was very fortunate that I had
spider senses so to
you know I didn't quite have Spyder
hearing after that first little episode
but I still I still have the rest of it
I mean I I could smell you in more than
one case I sniffed out an ambush I could
smell them
I could smell their body odor I could
smell what they had to eat I knew they
were up in front of us I could just feel
things like that so we had that we sent
in team okay we had a code word that we
just transmitted that meant you know one
of them team okay moving north moving
whatever directions was this a daytime
early more first light insertion I was
late afternoon yeah it wasn't the last
light thing again you know so we had
time to to move for a ways and then you
know eventually stop you know for the
night and typically what we would do is
do like we call it a fishhook
you'd move along a little ways and then
you would make a turn and you would come
back down 50 meters or so so if someone
was tracking you you'd hear them go by
because they were following your trail
and I would put very quickly I learned
to put out what we call tow poppers it
was a little small anti-personnel mine
plastic and you know I had c4 in it it
would take your leg off or most do you
leg if you stepped on it and I had a lot
of experience in the wood which I know
how people are gonna track you I know
where they're going to walk I know where
they're going to step and particularly
if there's a log for someone they have
to go across they'll always step right
on the other side of it and that's where
I'd put it you know I put it right where
they're going to step my cover it back
up and sometimes I put my foot just a
light footprint on top of it and then if
they came you'd hear that thing go off
and you knew you got one
and he was probably gonna die he'd bleed
to death
because they didn't have hospital
anything out there so you had him and if
he was just leading a larger group I
typically they would open fire they
didn't know where you were they just
start spraying the woods but you know
you're way back here and they're up in
front of you now so that gives you a
chance to decide if you're gonna move
out or not so anyway we set up and the
jungle the jungle just swallows you as
it starts to get dark it just closes in
all around you and if you're under you
know double canopy jungle it gets dark
fast if you're under triple it's pretty
dark during the daytime but at night you
can't see anything it's just totally
dark and I was thinking as it was
getting dark and you know at first I
thought I'm a little nervous because I
can't see even though I had just you
know had tremendous night vision like an
owl but I couldn't see and I thought
that they can't see either and the
difference is between us and them is
we're not moving they have to move
without making any noise and if they
make any noise we know where they are we
know they're out there so what I did was
I created for me a 4d bubble around me
so I would just start with whatever
direction I was facing and then what's
out there what sounds do I hear what
bugs do I hear what noises do I hear and
I take the next quadrant the next
quadrant until I had going all the way
around so I knew the sounds and all four
quadrants and then I would raise it up
because up above you I mean you got
birds you got monkeys you got different
things that are happening in the trees
different sounds up there and you you
incorporate all this together and now
you're used to a particular level of
noise and each one of these quadrants
and then the sound of silence was the
trigger I you know to where I could
actually wake up if any quadrant went
quiet it would wake me up if anybody
moves and one of those quadrants the
bugs in that area will stop chirping
they will just get quiet all of a sudden
and if they get quiet something is out
there and that that alerts you either
you know where they're coming from and
it might be a tiger you know it might be
some other large animal but something
just stopped them scared them so I said
you know the darks my friend they can't
see me and I've got area weapons out
there claymores I can set off the
Claymore if they see a big ball of fire
and I take out a bunch of people but
they don't know where I am and then you
know the next level of the frag grenades
you throw a grenade big ball of fire a
lot of fragments but they don't know
where it came from so you still don't
see as long as you don't pull the
trigger on the weapon they don't know
where you are so I decided this is this
is pretty cool when it gets dark yeah
that's all I'll find you if you're up
here how long would it take when you
guys would settle into a perimeter how
long would it take for the noise the
silence that you had created to to
escalate again to normal jungle levels
within 30 minutes that's up once
everybody's down and and the rule was
once you're down you're down you do not
move again until morning because anybody
moving is a bad guy and we wouldn't we
would all precision ourselves so that
you know I could reach echo over here or
the guy on the next side I mean to wake
him up or alert him something was
happening and that goes arms so big I
can't really do this but if I could have
your arm if you want to wake somebody up
without terrifying them grab them right
there and just slowly squeeze
if you just slow the squeeze like that
what you'll see is their eyes start to
open up and they just come to and you
know when we trained to do that so
people knew if you get squeezed you open
your eyes that's the only thing you
would start listening what are you here
and it might be your turn to be on guard
or it might be there's any me out here
well that's crazy I just got chicken
skin from that I can only imagine how
long what would you guys do 50% security
and 50% sleeping what'd you guys do last
night didn't really need it yeah
sometimes we drop down to 30% but I mean
I know teams everybody goes asleep but I
not not with me I'm not going there
somebody's gonna be awake and we're here
and you know sometimes you had to sleep
you would you wouldn't sleep on top of
the ridge you had to get off on the side
and you try to get into a thicket you
try to get into a steep area so you
learn to sleep straddle trees so you
straddle it so you won't slide on down
the hill at night it's a little
uncomfortable at first you go get set up
right but once you do you know you can
sleep like that
keep your arms to your rucksack because
you wanted your rucksack to go with you
if you had to leave in a hurry
your load-bearing equipment never came
off the weapon was always fastened to
you with a cord that went through a snap
link on the shoulder your load-bearing
gear you'd have it laying across your
lap so you know you could put your hands
on it real easy and turn it and shoot it
as yeah if you had to you had your knife
where you could access that you know
easily quietly in case you needed some
and then nobody mood and then that first
overnight mission that you did what was
what was the purpose of the operation
and we were going to find us
relatively small it's hanging in size
element okay and there's how many of you
guys mmm this mission is probably seven
so there's 70 you looking for five
hundred enemy North Vietnamese regulars
one of the things I think I know it
sounds a little crazy one is they just a
lot crazy one of the things you have to
understand about a SOG team is SOG teams
were small but they carried a really big
stick given the stick might be 30
minutes away before you could use it
and sometimes our but man you had a big
stick because if you engage the enemy as
soon as you submitted the word prairie
fire over the radio everything flying
within range of that team was diverted
everything any aircraft that had
ordnance on any mission that was going
on was set aside it all came to you it
was unbelievable I mean I had a I had a
mission one time where I had 14 covers
in RB waiting on their turn to come in
because I had to bring them in and
between the l4s that were coming in and
the sky Raiders that would come they
were all I mean it was just unreal you
know what would show up once you got in
trouble yeah I guess that that is the
security blanket
although bad weather then you're in
trouble
nighttime you could do a few some at
nighttime but you know we didn't have
the night vision the aircraft didn't
have the technology that they have today
so the night time was a problem for him
you could do something called combat sky
spots where the elf force could come in
and and and drop 500-pound bombs but
they were doing it based on radar so you
had to start them like 2500 3000 meters
away and bring them in because you
didn't know where they were gonna land
they would be somewhere you know
and in that circle but you had to let
something hit and then start to work it
so yeah the night time you know could be
a problem yeah you got you got a book
here you mentioned it really quickly
it's called the stress effect and it's
it's about leadership and
decision-making but you have some some
stories in it that are that are worth
talking about I want to read one of them
right now so it says for almost two
years I've been training to lead a
Special Operations team into combat
during those two years I'd successfully
completed US Army Ranger School Special
Forces training become a member of the
most elite military force in the world
when I got to base camp in Vietnam 1968
I erected a six foot tall two-by-four
board in the dirt and wrapped hemp rope
around the top eight inches of the board
to provide a striking surface every day
in camp I pounded the striking pad with
my fist and my feet continuing to
improve my accuracy and power I had been
trained in Ranger and Special Forces a
hand-to-hand combat and it earned a
black belt in the Korean martial art of
Taekwondo I'd become an expert with all
Special Operations weapons as well I
quickly found myself so you guys you had
some introduction to two martial arts
mm-hmm and they were teaching you guys
some striking capability did you guys
learn any grappling at all yeah I mean
you did that in Special Forces and in
Ranger School you did you know the
military version of a hand-to-hand but I
had trained in you know Taekwondo when I
was in college I broke my hand one night
in a little pub and I thought there's
got to be a broke your hand on a pub or
now you broke on a pub attendee there
was an attendee that ran in the ran into
my hand and broke it and I was thinking
there's got to be a better way than this
you know I've seen these guys jumping
around doing kung fu or whatever on
movies so I I found this tak mando place
you know right off campus there and I
and I said you know I need toughen up a
little bit I'm tired of you know getting
hurt right on back to the book I quickly
found myself deep inside enemy territory
leading my elite team of three Americans
and four mercenaries on a classified
mission every human within a hundred
miles was the enemy the temperature was
110 degrees the humidity was a hundred
percent the salt from our own
perspiration constantly burned our eyes
mosquitoes swarmed each of us carried 35
to 40 pounds of ammunition grenades and
water on our load bar bearing harness
and a 75 pound rucksack on our back no
one wore an armored vest or a helmet
because these would add too much extra
weight and would be too hot we were
operating under triple-canopy jungle
that allowed very little light to come
through and no air movement it rained
every day everything was wet the bushes
in the ground were covered with small
leeches that began to move up and down
frantically when they sensed our body
heat thinking they would have a meal
soon they attached themselves to us
without our noticing them the next day
we would find them on our faces chest
arms and legs filled with blood and the
size of our the end being the size of
our thumbs the physical and mental
stress was very high this type of
mission required complete silence no
talking for days just handed arm signals
or notes there could be absolutely no
noise while moving we were traveling
along at a snail's pace of a hundred
yards an hour every step in every foot
placement warp leap pre-planned toe down
first then slowly the heel this
technique was designed to muffle the
noise of any small branches that might
be broken if we accidentally placed our
weight on them each team member had an
area of responsibility for maintaining
vigilance as we moved we were always
looking for booby traps ambushes enemy
personnel poisonous snakes and tigers we
couldn't forget the 500-pound hungry
Tigers we knew a North Vietnamese Army
force was very close to us we just
didn't know exactly where we spent most
the day moving up to the top of a ridge
one step at a time without making a
sound
just as we neared the top the point man
signaled to us to halt to get down he
could hear a large group of enemy
soldiers just over the ridge our hearts
began to race and a journal and spiked
our seven-man team was about to come
face to face with over 180
trained North Vietnamese Army soldiers
our stress level soared and our
attention became focused we knew
everything we we knew everything could
literally explode at any second the
closest help was an hour away we could
make no mistakes we could not be
discovered I moved forward into a
position to observe the enemy soldiers
who were less than 40 yards down the
other side of the ridge from our
location they appeared to have finished
eating and were getting ready to move up
the ridge towards our location I
signaled the team that we needed to move
quickly
although the ground was muddy slippery
and steep we tried to move as quickly
and quietly as possible he was going to
be very difficult to avoid contact with
them and contact would be deadly I was
about 20 feet behind the point man
moving deliberately tightly gripping the
handle of my car 15 machine gun with my
right hand while using my left hand to
steady myself by grabbing bushes as I
moved it started to rain hard making it
even more difficult to get us help if we
were discovered we could hear the enemy
talking on the other side of the ridge
then out of nowhere I was hit so hard
from the high side of the ridge that my
weapon was knocked out of my hand and my
feet left the ground and I was falling
backward down the side of the steep
Ridge instinctively I grabbed my
attacker as I fell and took him with me
my stress level was so high that all my
hand-to-hand combat training
automatically kicked in as I tumbled
down the incline in the rain and mud I
literally ripped my attacker limb from
limb
biting pulling and breaking any part I
could get my hands on I used every
deadly move I knew and actually heard
the sounds of bones breaking although
the entire event lasted only a few
seconds it appeared to pass in slow
motion a stream of thoughts and
questions went through my mind where did
this guy come from how did I miss seeing
him does he have a knife how can I get
my knife is he alone will he call his
comrades before I can silence him then
it was over as quickly as it began
we will wedged hard against a large tree
that's large tree that stopped our
tumble down the ridge the impact
momentarily knocked the breath out of me
the attacker was not moving apparently I
was the winner
all my hand-to-hand combat training had
paid off
looking up the ridge I saw some of my
team members looking down at me with
sheer horror and shock on their faces it
must have been almost as terrifying for
them as it was for me I thought
everyone's life hung in the balance but
I had won the fight mano a mano I had
saved the team as I begin to untangle
myself from my attacker the world
suddenly came back into focus now I had
the same horror and shock on my face as
my team members did I had just used all
my expert hand-to-hand combat techniques
on a banana tree in that part of the
world worms eating around the bottom of
the banana trees which weakens them and
caused them to fall without warning I
was lucky enough to be in the right
place at the right time and be
blindsided by a falling banana tree
fortunately two components and to this
event ultimately saved us first I was
hit so hard and unexpectedly that my
weapon was knocked out of my hand
preventing me from firing at the tree
and giving away our position second it
was raining so hard that the enemy
soldiers did not notice the commotion we
completed our mission and returned to
Vietnam unharmed except for my ego
I have heard however that banana trees
in that part of the world still tremble
at the mention of my name
[Laughter]
[Music]
embarrassing yeah stress levels oh so
high it just you know you're locked
loaded you ready to go and something
triggers you and you go for it you know
you react it was just just the the
instinct somebody had me and it was me
or him and you know I just unleashed
everything I go ahead until I killed a
banana tree Hey yeah I can walk by one
today even in other countries and he
trembled they know they know they know
the legend is real yeah you can see
their little uns turn and watch me to
make sure I go on by
it is amazing you know the point of you
telling that story talking about stress
and and you know I I one thing that I
noticed about it is when we are
anticipating something oftentimes we
will we will see what we are
anticipating so when we are predicting
enemy combat then that's what we're
gonna see and you have another great
vignette in here about a shooting that
took place in New York and it was you
know a guy that was standing in the
stoop of a doorway and the police
officer see him and he looked kind of
suspicious and eventually well when he
moved they said oh he's trying to run
from us so now they draw their weapons
and the next thing he does is reach into
his pocket they started shooting and
once one person starts shooting they all
start shooting and they end up putting
40-plus rounds in and or into the guy
and into the surround a guy you know cuz
they didn't they didn't shoot very
accurately but you know it turns out
that the guy was just a normal citizen
that fit the description of you know fit
the description of a person that had
conducted some crimes in the area but
you know it wasn't like he was it wasn't
like a specific description I think it
was like as a black guy in this
neighborhood Oh looks pretty close but
what they anticipated seeing and what
they got kind of mentally ready for and
then he makes a move to get away from
them in their mind he's making a move to
get away from them in his mind he's just
trying to get out of the way who knows
what these cops are doing but they can't
be after me and then the next thing is
they're yelling at him oh I better get
them some ID so he reaches into his
pocket what do they think he's reaching
for they're anticipating he's reaching
for a weapon so they kill him so that's
a great lesson learned and you know you
talk a lot in the book the stress effect
about you call it awareness being aware
of what's going on I always use the word
detachment being detached from all the
chaos and emotion and how what a great
power it is to have that you know it's
the same word or different word same
meaning the awareness that you talk
about but that exam
right there what you're anticipating
there's a good chance that what you're
anticipating you're gonna see you're
gonna see regardless of what reality is
yeah it's not a banana tree North
Vietnamese soldier highly trained and
skilled and he's trying to take me out
and doing a good job because I'm falling
backwards I can't shoot him and yeah I
mean in the story you're talking about
as they approach him and start shooting
you know the two first two guys to get
that get there one starts shooting and
what happens is some of the bullets they
hitting on you know different parts of
the stoop there and start to ricochet
back that's right in their mind he's
shooting at him I mean the bullets had
coming back out him you think he's
shooting the the other guy with him
trips on the steps and falls so his
partner thinks Manny they hit him he's
down the other two were up there they
think he's down and you know they all
just continue to shoot and an innocent
guy so we we see what were you expecting
you have to be careful with that then it
happens you know it happens all the time
when there's dremen starts flowing
you're gonna do a lot of things that you
need to keep it under control and in
their wife I'm part of it probably
getting off track here but some of it is
practice practice practice you know go
through the immediate action drills you
keep doing it and doing it and doing it
now one of the things I used to make my
guys the practice that they really
didn't like was when we've gone on a
mission because you're going to be out
there for so long you the one zero cared
a medical kit
so I have a medical kit with me everyone
there carried it came in a can back then
just a little can about that big around
you had it taped on the back of your
well gear and had a bag of ringers
solution and a blood expander
you know because when you when you get
hit most of the time what you die of
from a gunshot woman is you believe to
death you can't get the blood you know
stop to you in time so we all carried a
bag of ringers solution so you know you
could get an IV right there on the spot
you know my thinking was especially
after the first incident when I having
trouble getting the magazine in the
weapon I don't want one of my guys
trying to put that needle in my arm in
that condition and he's jabbing all over
my arm and I'm laying there bleeding to
death I need the blood so I said okay
guys here's what we gonna do we have a
little practice so I had been over to
the dispensary and I had gotten some
needles and I brought him over and I
said we're gonna practice putting the
needle in each other mm-hmm so that you
know we're getting shot at you've done
it before it won't be the first time
that you've tried to put a needle in the
vein they did not like them that guy's
okay now swap partners theirs do it
again let's do it again and every so
often we would go through that drill
let's practice that's right because open
and you can you know you don't want to
have never tried to open I can before
when somebody's shooting at you and your
buddy is bleeding to death you you have
to been through the whole process let's
do it well these lessons that you
learned that you passed on I mean
everything from you know getting on the
ground and and patrolling 100 meters
than waiting that's that's what we were
trying now I will say that once you got
night vision things are different cuz
you didn't need to wait a half an hour
delay your night vision adjust you could
you could go but you know we used to we
used to do the same thing we used to get
give each other IVs with Redlands flash
line that night underneath the poncho
because that's what you're gonna have to
do and and so those are the kind of
things that you have to train you have
to train and people that think that that
that horrible thought that creeps in
your mind that well when the time rises
when the time arises I'll know what to
do that is not the truth right there I
got a quick question for you how did you
get the name dynamite was that your
nickname did they assign that to you
because I'm surprised at this point your
nickname wasn't but
a tree fort fortunately you got your
codename on day one and so after we got
the briefing they're denying and then
you know we had to select a code name
I wanted Ranger Ranger was already taken
so they said here are some others and I
saw dynamite and I said you know I I
really do like to blow things up I'm
small and you know dynamite probably
works for me I mean I believe my
neighbors windows out when I was a
teenager one time with a rocket that
exploded on the launch pad
I didn't intend for that to happen but
you know I was always blowing things up
so and then when I was there in
Southeast Asia okay I blew things up all
the time I blew bridges up I blew up all
kinds of things I always carried a lot
of demo with me good good nickname and
that was your callsign - is that your
callsign when you're in the field did
you know and well it would be my
callsign if I was wounded or something
like that God but call signs that we use
they're always three-letter groups okay
got it all right you you mentioned in
your notes here that you gave me an
operator you guys hit with you guys got
hit with gas yeah that was uh that had
to be unexpected I was still with Dex
team yeah we we had planned and
rehearsed for everything and we went in
it wasn't a hot LZ or didn't appear to
be we didn't roll any fire going in I we
got off the aircraft the aircraft you
know took off we're on the ground and
all of a sudden you know we couldn't see
you couldn't breathe this stuff is
coming across the LZ and you know we're
coughing and gagging because we didn't
have masks with us masks
we're like helmets and flak jackets
that's extra waste you got to carry
and unless we were intended to use gas
we didn't carry it because it was just
very very rare that the NVA would use
gas and in this case we're on the LZ
here comes the gas we're not prepared
for it we had to call you know for the
aircraft to come back and get us out and
it creates a real problem for pilots if
they don't have masks and now all of a
sudden they're getting all of the the
gas coming in you know it's hard for
them to see the instrument panel to be
able to fly you know what they came back
in and and they got us out it was it
wasn't a pleasant experience and it was
one of those things we didn't plan part
you know because it was it was such a
rarity we just didn't do it I was
surprised we went through a gear list
with tilt and they always carried a gas
mask and of course because they always
carried a gas mask you know how many
times they came across I think the
number was zero Murphy's Law yeah you
know a lot of times we would carry gas
canisters we'd carry regular you know
like a CFCs grenade but we'd also
carried that the CS rounds for the m49
the 40 millimeter so we could shoot
those but if we carried ICS or the the
grenades then you know we cared the
masks too but it was the mass were
because we were going to use them and
you know if you use - you better have a
mask are you gonna be as bad off as the
other guys goes without fail the winds
kind of change and it's gotta come right
back on you and you're in trouble
Murphy's Law you got over you got
another note in here about a mission
it says tree roots this was I think this
this was my last mission with Artie
Alabama with wood deck and we had gone
up we made the little fish hook we came
back it was early afternoon and we're
gonna take a break for a little while so
we had but I'd claymores I had put a toe
popper out
and there are some strange trees in that
area I'm still not sure what they're
called but they almost looked like
Rockettes with fins the roots kind of
came out and I mean it kind of you know
they grow up the tree maybe t feet or so
and they come out like fins all the way
around so we were taking a break so I
thought you know I'll just lay down
between you know these roots and I you
know you won't be able to see me because
I'm kind of down in there and that's
where I'll take my break and then we
hear the tow piper go off
I heard that loud scream and soon as the
tow Piper went off it's just as barrage
of ak-47 fire coming some of it you know
in our direction some of it in other
directions they didn't know exactly
where everywhere but in that first
barrage coming through I had three a.k
rounds come through the road on my left
side right across my shirt I had just
exhaled and through the road on the
other side if I had had just inhale it
would taken the top of my chest off when
it came by so he just grazed me
you know coming across and that's it
they probably should get out of here
so got the briefs are not providing any
you know actually cover for me just a
little concealment so I jumped around
behind the tree and you know we set off
the claymores had a full fledge
firefight going on and eventually he had
to work gunships and things and get
extracted but one of the things that I
also did was he got another taste of the
impact of adrenaline because when I came
out from behind a tree I had taken my
arms out of the straps on the rucksack
so I had to grab it was my hand I
grabbed it with my left hand you know
and it weighed probably 75 pounds but
I'm not a big guy but I'm tossing that
75 pound rucksack around like it's a
pillow
and you know it's going to go with me as
we fight our way you know down the ridge
and toward the LZ but I paid for it you
know later on you know after we got
extracted to realize I had pulled most
muscles and my shoulders because the
muscles wasn't designed to handle that
much weight but I had so much adrenaline
pumping pumping through our system yeah
yeah so as soon as you guys get
contacted as soon as that those rounds
start coming here calling prayer our
emergency prioritize and then how long
has it taken before aircraft show up on
station usually you'll have something
within 30 minutes that you might be able
to work a gunship or something like that
but for the extraction ships it might be
an hour depending you know on how far in
there you are and it might be longer
than that
but if you had bad weather nobody's
coming I think I say you know they can't
find you how good was the weather
prediction at that time you know if you
guys will you guys able to look out in a
day and say like hey there's gonna be
storms moving through here tomorrow we
at the different CNCs we had our own Air
Force meteorologists that track the
weather gave brother weather briefings
you know two or three times a day you
know to the command group the teams
would give them we would get them before
we would go out so that we would know
kind of what they expect and you know we
didn't launch unless the weather looked
like it was going to be good you know
for the insertion because you didn't
want to get out there and all of a
sudden you couldn't use the assets that
you had with you so but still it's kind
of like today the best weather
predictions that are made are the ones
the day after you know we can tell you
what probably happened yesterday or at
least with a high probability of what
happened yesterday but the weather
change you know it's a where we were
north most of the time is a rain forest
I mean he's got rain so it's gonna read
every day it's gonna rain and the clouds
would roll right down on top of the the
and just totally conceal it conceal the
ridgelines they're not only or you under
triple-canopy jungle alight now you've
got a cut of cloud cover over I mean up
above that they can see fine but they
can't see where you are they can't you
know you fire the flyer flares out they
won't see him it's there in the clouds
is is it always the one zero that's
carrying the radio and talking to the
aircraft or the who usually was doing
that for you I know that tilt said he
did it he would be like yep I'm gonna
talk to the aircraft most of the time I
carried the radio I mean you had you had
a guy yeah one of the three Americans
was supposed to be carrying the radio
usually the one too if he had a one too
but I carried mine almost all the time
and but even if I didn't care it I
wanted to talk so bring it bring it over
here I want to tell them you know what I
need to have done so you know that gave
me another 25 pounds plus depending on
how many batteries I carried more weight
to go in my rucksack and that's if we
used you know the PRC 25 or seven years
Alvin but I think tilt mention that one
point we had a commander take over CCN
who said you're going to carry the KY 38
secure radio which the PRC 77 was about
25 pounds and then it had to connect
into the KY 38 which was the the same
squares but but thicker you know and
they had to fasten together so some
people would stack up on a rucksack one
under the other most people were wearing
the 77 in the back and and 38 in the
front to help you balance you know going
up and down the hills a good theory but
you know I to me and my experience said
the more you can look like an empty pair
of fatigues laying on the ground the
greater your chance of survival when
somebody's shooting at you so the more
stuff you put on your chest around your
waist that raises you up in the air
makes you more so I mean I get my
rucksack shot up all the time I'm a
heavy laden earring bullet citizens in
through the rucksack because it was
sticking up you know about me but when
you put that KY 38 on your chest that
pushes your body up another six inches
in the air so now the chances of you
getting hit instead of the rucksack go
up so I didn't like to carry it I want
it used it a few times I mean it it had
a pretty high malfunction rate and then
because it's not just on you you got to
make sure that their aircraft that
you're trying to talk to is running
their encryption everybody has doesn't
have to have that same encryption which
is an interesting story would make it to
you a little later about that but yeah
it was a pain but I wanted to talk on
the radio and you guys did I know till
they didn't carry like a belt-fed
machine gun in there elements I think he
said they never did which to me was
surprising because like you talk to
Vietnam say oppa tunes and even like my
SEAL platoons in Iraq we carried as many
belt-fed machine guns as we could like
we wanted to have massive firepower but
I guess for you guys the jungle the way
it was too much my my team carried one I
named 16 machine gun him sexes are heavy
they are having indeed my team carried
one one time because I thought it would
be cool I carried the machine gun
because I thought man the firepower I'll
have with this thing
yeah I can show those guys on the other
side here what war is all about and we
made contact and I opened up with that
baby and I learned a lesson
really
and it made sense you know when it
happened because we always teach you got
to take the machine gun out ships you
fire to wherever that machine gun is
take that Joker out and that's what they
did and all of a sudden everybody's
shooting yeah I mean this stuff is just
coming in on me and it's just eating
everything up and I'm getting behind the
tree and keeping my head around I'm
shooting the machine gun around the side
of the tree but I can't really see what
I'm doing but I couldn't take my head
around there they'd take it off and so
after that mission I said that's enough
of that
I mean I'm not carrying right there now
when you know when we put team if we put
two teams together to make what we call
the spike team you know where we were
going in with with the intent of
engaging the enemy and not running then
we would care you know to em 60s at
least and then you know when you care in
the m60 everybody on the team has to
carry m16 ammo I mean everybody's got it
at least 100 brown belt William you know
plus the machine gun is carrying all
that extra weight and so I mean it's it
doesn't just weight down the machine gun
it's everybody on the team now it's
still gonna carry all those 40
millimeter you know grenades with them
for the m79 you still got to carry that
you still got to carry you're actually
claymores you got carry all your mission
equipment and now I'm giving you another
15 20 pounds of machine gun ammo to
carry along with you you know there's
only five or six of you if the weight
just goes up so fast that we didn't do
it yet I guess another now that I'm
sitting here thinking about it the fact
that you guys were in generally enclosed
terrain pretty tight it wasn't like you
needed massive cover fire to cover
ground to put you know you could didn't
have to fire maneuver because you take
three steps and almost on the enemy
can't see you anymore
so that that makes a little bit of sense
- what was your op temple-like you know
we're talking about these missions how
often were you guys going out that's an
interesting story and the it varied by
team and like
well and in the 12 months that I was
there I went out 18 times which was
waiver yarn way beyond what an officer
led team would do I don't know that the
other teams were going out that
frequently you know and that shorter
period the paper that you signed when
you joined solid said you know live
volunteer to go anywhere to do anything
for six months or six missions whichever
comes first
got it at the end of the six missions or
the six months I've got to say I
volunteered to do it some more
so you had just you know a little safety
valve in there to give you a chance to
kind of wake up and say this is not a
smart thing to do and and here's my
ticket to do something different right
well that's like sort of like the
bombers in in World War two that had to
do 25 missions over Europe and if they
did 25 then they then they could go and
do something else go home right most of
them didn't make it but yeah that's
pretty telling when they say that you
only have to complete six missions that
doesn't sound like a big deal you must
be thinking yourself if they only want
me to do six of these things they gotta
be pretty if I only have to go out six
times in six months I mean I've got a
good deal you know the grunts are going
out do you everyday and fighting you
know or doing something or being exposed
and no so you had that and remember that
SOG missions a SOG mission really is an
out of country mission you know as tilt
says across the fence you go into
another country when you see the
casualties you know the ki AES of SOG at
least in the beginning they also had
South Vietnam mmm that's not where we go
so you were good you're going out but in
between those missions you might do
something in-country
Lynne then black one of tilts big
buddies they were on the same team and
stuff for a while in was a you know or
just the unbelievable one zero and he
and I kind of became friends and in
between missions we would do things like
why don't we take some where guys
tonight and let's go or the marble
mountain set up an ambush I guarantee
we'll get somebody let's go do that
what about tomorrow afternoon you want
to take some of our guys let's go search
some of the caves and more marble
mountain those Joker's are in there
which is that's fine you know so we
would we would do a lot of things like
that just for fun so to speak but you
know because you know compared to the
regular mission I mean this is a no
brainer you just go where there an issue
some people you know you catch them in
the cave and I was there 240 miles deep
in Cambodia
alone and when we you know we we can be
back in time for lunch
so and then you had you know marble
mountain the two combat outpost teams
would rotate up there you had to keep
you know two teams up there all the time
so in between missions you know they you
might go up there for a week or two
weeks at a time and then come back down
and start mission proud you know for
another mission and to go back out so it
wasn't like you were just sitting around
in between the missions you were always
doing something place you've done a lot
of training and preparation for the next
mission that you had coming up
so you see stayed pretty busy how long
would it take you to brief a mission
when you were going on we might start
with the initial briefing as a day
briefing this is what we're going to go
to do is we're we're going to go do it
and depending on what the mission was I
might say okay so we're going to go over
until a place that was called monkey
mountain we're going over to monkey
mountain because it's a good place over
there for us to rehearse the actual
mission the raid the ambush whatever it
was we're going to do we can go over
there and get in some you know realistic
rehearsals so we might go spend a few
days over there just doing that and we
while we're there we rehearse our oral
in procedures put in claymores where
they would put them I would put the team
in a different place every night so that
you going to do okay let's look at the
terrain we're in now what's the most
likely approach is why do we need to
defend the claymores where did we put
the tow poppers
what's our avenue of egress how do we
get out of here if they come at us from
this direction of this direction where
did we go and where's where the closest
tells these that we're going to go to
and how do we get there everybody needs
to know that you know whether you're
American or indeed you've got to know
where he is you gotta know how to get
there and so we would we would do the
training like that but particularly
mission specific for what we're coming
up on and then as you got closer you get
much more specific and then when you got
to the launch site you would have the
mission briefing where your air assets
would be there so the pilots who are
going to fly your insertion and gunship
pilots Air Force representative for the
AU unease that we're going to be there
they'll force that we're going to be
there you know so you would have the big
briefing there that everybody would
agree on everything and make sure you
had all the call signs and everything
down and continue to see actions the
Covey said anything about him we'd
always have a covey out there for the
forward air controller that we could
talk to you and could look down and tell
us what you know he was seeing might be
able to see the bad guys coming to us or
whatever and get more assets for us so
it was a it's a big deal I mean because
you you might have four gunships to to
481 each guy Raiders two to four L fours
you've got cubby you've got the
insertion ships that you're going in
with you've got trailing ships in case
those get shot down
that are flying empty so they can drop
down and and pick you up sometimes you
might have a ship with the medics in it
because you're expecting casualties you
know so it was a it could be a big air
show sometimes going and fit in if you
were going if you're going to North
Vietnam you had to have the off force
you know I mean it was just required for
the mission some of the others Laos
Cambodia you could go without the health
force and you just use the honey
Skyraiders but if you're going north
vietnam you better have the health force
with you because they could send a MIG
down there ask people if they wanted to
so you had to worry about you know air
cover as well as hitting big targets and
l4 you know you can get your attention
real fast and the sky Raiders you know
do too because they they're they fly low
slow and they're carrying their own
weight and ordnance and they can put it
right next to you you tell them where
you want that 20 millimeters hitting 10
feet over there and right along beside
you or whatever their ordnance they're
carrying you get your attention I mean
those jokers are good all right so you
so how many missions did you do with RT
Alabama four and then after that did you
get the up check from deck to to become
a 1-0 yes so I had gotten that I mean
already I had it before we did the four
but we knew that fov one was going to
close down and when it closed down the
teens were going to get scattered around
so I knew I would get a team but I would
get one somewhere else so we just stayed
together you know for those four
missions and then when we moved when I
moved to D name to CCN then I took over
RT Michigan and
our team Michigan was the one that had I
don't remember who the one zero had been
on that one but Eldon Bardwell was the
one one on that one
so I I took over over that and you know
you know the Gaza he was late at the
time hey you just back for things yeah I
mean that he was already a legend well
he he already had a good reputation good
reputation you know so we got along well
because I had to ask about him because I
didn't write you know he was a different
camp I didn't know about it so I had
asked about him and everybody had talked
to you said man you know this guy was
good he had he been asking everyone else
about you to ask you about me he don't
and I said what they tell you he said
well I talked to you know sergeant Jones
and you know it was impressive because
he said and you know I had total faith
in him
he said Thompson is the only lieutenant
I've ever met that you could give a map
and compass to and he could tell you
where he was and he can navigate you to
any place he wanted to go and he said
you just don't find lieutenants like
that so he said I was good enough for
him if I knew where we were
yeah so isn't it surprising that that
that would be a skill that's so needed
and and that people didn't actually have
it sometimes it's crazy and these days
well you know kids kids are relying on
the GPS
yeah and they forget about some of those
land nav skills and it always cracked me
up because they're now there to a point
where they really rely on the GPS I
don't know their pace count and you know
I'd be walking on a training operation
you know say okay you know just not even
thinking about looking at a GPS because
I did a map study didn't know where
we're at and those younger guys know
they just they just don't have this cut
not all of them of course you know we
still get some guys that
great at it but it's just a different
time so you take over this uh you take
over this new team
you got bars well which I'm sure you
heard me talking about it with tilt but
but you know he was when I was a young
officer I just got picked up for
Commission and I went to Germany and he
was the guy in charge over there and so
and my boss who was a outstanding guy
who was a great mentor to me but he he
would kind of tell me you know about
about the old man he said bar as well
said this bar as well said that you know
so that was pretty neat for me to make
this connection and here you are sitting
to here that uh actually he he was your
he was your one one yeah and he I mean
he was very knowledgeable very good and
I you know I was impressed with him
right from the beginning I thought I
mean this guy was good and you know when
when we went out on an operation he's
this cool and calm
you know when his shooting started I
mean he was good but I mean he had he
had experience I mean he was a case I
was the team there the siege of Khe Sahn
I mean he was he was there I mean where
they just got hammered for you know
several weeks there he was you know they
were that Special Forces detachment he
had recruited actually had recruited
some of the team members that we had and
this was a yard team they all liked him
they all had a lot of respect for him
and you know he was a support guy I just
never thought then you know where he
would end up I figured you know he if he
doesn't get killed he's probably going
to be somebody at some point but I
didn't expect to see him and I guess it
was in the in the late 70s I saw him at
Fort Bragg know I guess it was in the
80s I saw him at Fort Bragg
and he was a captain mm-hmm and I'm
thinking you know how can you be a
captain huh you know I'm a major you
respect for the last time I saw you then
now you're a captain and and I I thought
that was great so we hung out a little
bit he was in Delta or her so we chatted
about you know Delta Force and all that
kind of stuff and you know we had some
good times over there together at Bragg
and then I guess you know the next time
I actually saw him he was a major he was
that come in and going through the
command and General Staff College and
I'm thinking I'm about to get promoted
I'm still a major - I just got doing
this and you know then the next thing
he's a lieutenant colonel and then the
full colonel and you know ends up a
Major General and he just he's just
constantly going and everybody kept
telling me get out of Special Forces
Special Forces is a kiss of death or an
austere you stay in Special Forces
you're not going anywhere he did it I
mean not only did he did great on that
tour with SOG he did a second tour
he ended up come and not just being in
Delta he came back and commanded Delta
Force and then overall Special
Operations and all this kind of stuff I
mean just unbelievable do you notice any
qualities I mean you said you looked at
him and you were like oh yeah this this
guy will do well if he lives
was there any qualities that stand out
you know if they're if they're if you're
a young enlisted guy in the Army right
now or in any branch and and you said
yourself you know I want to be a good
soldier is there anything that you
noticed about them that you would give
us like guidance to young young trooper
out there mission focus you tell them
this is what what you need to do or
where you need to go I'm he's gonna make
it happen
cool calm
he was a smart guy I mean he didn't brag
about it when you talk to him just very
humble and but you could tell I mean
he's smart mm-hmm I mean he's thinking
about what you're saying and what he
comes out with and when he makes
recommendations and talks about things
and you need to be listening because
he's thought to step through no but no
fear from a combat perspective I mean if
the bad guys are coming he's gonna take
him out and you know demonstrated that
you know on several occasions with me
demonstrated it later on I think you got
I think he got hit the next mission
after he was with me but he had put on
ak-47 vest you know a song got shot and
gunshot at Jackson or something yeah
magazine you know he poked through
nothing like a little hole in him but it
didn't go all the way through but and
then he you know on another mission he
got shot a couple more times and another
mission he b40 rocket hit the team
everybody responded he had a piece of
shrapnel go into his cheek and kind of
lodged behind his eye you know so he's
bleeding like a stuck pig and you know
the bad guys had come in and you know he
takes out 20 of them because he's got a
RPD you know the the Soviet kind of a
light machine gun and he he just taken
people out right and left
you know the whole everybody wounded
including him that's that's what he did
the only general on record that for a
personal firearm carried an ak-47 ak-47
he's walking around as a general officer
and instead of having that little pop
gun on his hip he's got an ak-47 slung
over his shoulder and he's telling you
know his deeds and by guards and
if we get in trouble you don't worry
about me said you guys take care of
yourself I'll take care of me you know
just down real out stab a baby you know
we we spend a lot of time up on a marble
mountain together just with the rotation
and stuff so we we spent time there you
know so we'd have those little fights
most nights the bad guys trying to come
up and get us that snipers had shoot at
us just before dark
there was one cave opening that was
almost on our level I don't know 50
meters away from us that if they work
their way up to that opening they could
shoot just about into us at night I've
got videos of that cave and you can see
how the marble it's just chipped off all
round the opening of that cave where we
were shooting out of midnight you know
when they're up in there that stuff so
we did a lot of stuff together and it
was a good relationship so one of the
one of the things you got in here in
your notes is um you guys did a mission
RT Michigan and you guys inserted into
the into the Laotian border with 101st
airborne it sounds like a pretty good
trick you know kind of a it was kind of
a when when he told us what they wanted
us to do I felt the sounds like Ranger
School this is exactly a scenario in
Ranger school what they tell you they
wanted you so we this was going to be a
walk-in mission so we would start on the
Vietnam side of the border and we would
walk over and allow stew into the area
they wanted us to go to and they wanted
us to do that from position where the
hundred and first was currently located
so there was a battalion from the 101st
that was set up right on the border and
so they coordinated to have us have our
team but on
steel pots all that kind of stuff come
on those the resupply helicopters we
came in with a resupply like we were you
know new troops coming to be there when
we jumped off and and then they they put
us in inside the perimeter but but in a
section and said you need to dig in you
know and all the little guys are looking
around saying what you need to dig a
hole Fox over to get in a fighting
position and the responsible we don't do
so I don't yeah you need to dig I mean
we're out here with people they only got
no bullets going everywhere you need to
dig in so it was a good thing we did it
goes and it got a little hairy you know
it was nice to be able to get down in a
hole and then I met with with a company
commander and patina leaders and their
forward to observer and I gave them our
plan you know here's what we're going to
do but what shocked them was I said okay
these coordinates I want you to pre-plan
that as an artillery target and here's
the name of it and I want one here and
here and here and these are the names
all I'm going to do is call that name
out you know target Roger I'm not gonna
give you coordinates saying you've got
to have that already planned when I say
Roger I expect the artillery I never had
artillery before so this was great we've
never in range of artillery and all of a
sudden that guy did I plan I planned
that stuff all over the place and saw
the what we did the next morning was at
first light we went down to the stream
with the water resupply team they go
down and fill all the canteens and
things up and bring them up so we went
down with them dressed like the hundred
and first when we got down there you
know we changed into our Batman suits
and gave them they all want some flak
jackets and all that stuff and they
threw them in bags and carry them back
up and we just you know went on across
the river and
the jungle they're on a mission so
hoping that the bad guys thought you
know nobody had come in that way so went
out on our mission there was a there was
a hatchet for spittoon that had been
inserted
you know much further out in the valley
but we we went in and I mean it was it
was just you know different and a cool
way to do something and and you know
when we got in contact I mean when I I
called for those targets they put it
right on so that was a cool thing it was
interesting that we had barge well and
the one team that was on the team with
us we had a little disagreement about
our exact location you know I'm telling
those two no I'm telling you we are
right here nice and no you're 200 meters
off I said there's no way so anyway we
in contact then I told him I said you
know if we where I am or where I'm
saying we are there's a fork in the
stream and there's a little foot bridge
going across one right out there about
150 meters in front of us there's a road
and there's a stream out here I said you
know I'll take you down here Twila we're
doing we made contact and we had to come
out on strings so when you're live
without your first time coming out on
strings no oh okay so you're picking us
up and they couldn't see me because here
in front of me but I'm reformed there
right there you're right it's shot but
you're like hey I was right ten digit
grid coordinates and they were right on
you know so what are you were you were
you just using pace Cal and use the pace
catch a train I you know I'd spent a lot
of time in the woods growing on so I and
and particularly in the dark I love
Dart I can I can feel the change in the
train I know if I'm going uphill or
downhill if I'm on a little side
whatever so I would take the section of
the map that I thought we were going to
operate in I just memorize it did you
guys have one to 50,000 maps or there
one to 24 yeah they were well we had
both but what we depending on the
distance that we were gonna go to her
but I could just I mean usually we
didn't go very far you know so you can
memorize if you're used to doing that
the section of the map I could see it in
my mind you know when we're moving you
know where we were any what the pace
counts where I knew quite the terrain
should look like you know where we were
I had Jack point set up that you know if
we're here we'll see the US if we're
here we'll see this so I could track it
plus I used the pace count so I I knew
where I was out there and that was one
thing that I I thought it was critical
because eventually you're gonna have to
call for help and you need to be able to
tell them where you are and under
triple-canopy jungle you're not shooting
Asmus to hilltops and things like that i
mean you got to know where you are on
the ground because you know the topology
and what it feels like what it looks
like and how far you've gone and the
skill set that I had no no more
important piece of information on the
battlefield than where you are you don't
know where you are it doesn't matter
where the enemy is because you can't
call for fire you can't maneuver on but
you know where you are when you guys
were well you guys just getting
overwhelmed is that why you guys had to
come out all the strings on that one
yeah how big was the enemy force to
think that you rolled into in your notes
here you said lots this has lots of NVA
I typically use the term lots meaning
you know 100 or more so how did you guys
stumble across them what I I'm sorry
where'd the contact come from like what
did that contact start like
it really started because headquarters
decided they needed to resupply us
because they wanted us to stay longer
and I was saying no don't
don't bring a helicopter right here and
hover over our position don't do that
yeah you got to get resupplied and they
did it anyway and so you know once you
have a chopper hovering above the canopy
they're dropping stuff down through it
the bad guys coming they're all over the
place anyway so there must be somebody
down there if nothing else they're going
to go get whatever fell out of a
helicopter and they did they came down
there and they were so kind of you know
messed up the afternoon in terms of what
we plan to do you know but but we got
out in the pits and extraction on
strings through you know double canopy
the jungle is rough but you you've been
dragged through the limbs of the trees
there's treetops the aircraft will
always start to to go forward and then
you're being drug through them and well
they want to get the hell out of that
fire right yeah because they're getting
shot at they don't want to stay there
long you're getting shot at and it's
hard for you to shoot because you're
twisting and turning and hitting leaves
and you know now they're behind you and
it's hard to shoot that way and you know
they're only going to take maybe four
people at a time out anyway so that
means you've got another chopper coming
in the bad guys know you're going out on
strings down and you got another
aircraft coming in to pick up the rest
of the team yeah I'm the team leader I'm
always first off first one on the ground
last one on the ground yes I'm coming
out with that last aircraft I'm the last
one you know to come up off the ground
and you know they've got you pretty well
zeroed in by them even though you know
you're starting with some gunships and
style
but you know the pilots don't like stay
in there and then but then they get over
the in this case you get over that
anti-aircraft fire I mean all of a
sudden weird 7,000 feet freezing AGL huh
Nazi level AGL hanging on the end of a
rope covered in sweat and I'm freezing
to death and I'm looking up you know and
I was I'm swinging back and forth so my
rope is rubbing back and forth on the
edge of the for the helicopter here we
got a long ways to go and it's starting
to fray the Rope up here and you know
are we gonna get to a place they can set
us down before that thing break sort of
all right so that runs you around the
level up a little bit and you know place
you shivering and then you know after
about 30 minutes if your legs are asleep
you can't walk because it's cut the
circulation off so even when you get to
wherever they gonna set you down you
can't stand up they have to come out and
get you and pick you up and put you in
the helicopter so it's another day at
SOG huh I know you did a snatch mission
you mentioned in these notes you did a
little a little you set up and set up
the ambush tried to capture someone it
doesn't seem like you mentioned a couple
times you weren't very successful at
capturing people yeah together is this
how you got your second nickname
terminator you know if they don't
cooperate you know sometimes they get
terminated you know in this one I mean
we we had rehearsed we had practice and
one of the techniques of the prisoners
snatch is if you have a trail that's
people are going to move up and down in
small groups you practice setting up an
ambush that has a dead spot in it so in
the in the middle of the ambush usually
no one's going to fire into
that zone the claymores are angled out
so that it creates a dead space there
you put a big block to see for there
that you're going to designate or
detonate it's the same you know same
time you set off the clay everything's
going to go out at the same time and
everybody's firing and you know the what
happens is whoever's lucky enough to be
standing in that dead spot then you get
hit with a bullet but the concussion
from that c4 stuns them yeah and you
know we practiced so it's stuns them and
then I've got a guy with me that's
designated as thumper
all right so his he and I are going
we're coming out of the bush as soon as
that stuff goes off and then dumpers job
is to see this guy standing there County
days and just take him down
you know dump him in the head and he
hits the ground I'm gonna hit him in the
thigh with the morphine Tourette so I'm
gonna pump him full of morphine and then
he'll do whatever we say
he's just calm and but in this case we
ended up killing that guy how many at
this point you've done however many
missions had you guys taking me
casualties in your teams yet yes
but I took most I mean a lot of people
got hit I didn't have anybody kill on
one of my teams until I got to party
Virginia you know the point man was
killed a lot of people were wounded
right after I left Virginia on their
next mission they just got hammered and
lost some people Americans got shot up
really bad both critical so they were
through with song but at this point
you've been used you you're being
continuing to be pretty lucky yeah it is
people ask me all the time I walk you
know
how do you survive that so I see you
I'll be lucky I mean and you call it
lucky and all the guide you can call it
whatever you want
but there's some kind of intervention
that prevents you from getting it you
can't sit in a helicopter like that
first one with that many bullets
crisscross and in there and not get hit
you know and I like a fraction of a
second between me being hit and you know
the other American being hit on those
kids I mean I had just pushed back when
I gotta pull the trigger miss me hit the
other guy and that happened on a regular
basis where you know I when I go speak a
lot of times people if it has a this
kind of flavor to it if they say
something about you know being in
Special Forces or something it's not
unusual for people to come out to me and
say I really thought you'd be taller
and I say if I'd been taller I'd be dead
I'm alive because I'm not tall my head
has been creased so many times I just
wouldn't be here so then did you would
DeBarge well took over for RT Michigan
yeah eventually we got to the point
where I mean boy boy was ready he could
have taken over before me but so we got
to the point we were I had to leave to
go do something different and I tell him
he's ready he can do this he's a spec
for ya with all those asses all that
responsibility and somewhere in there
you got a five I think but yeah but if
you if you were to go back and look at
sog 10.11 would people do that
and it used to be that neurologists
thought that your prefrontal cortex over
here where you make decisions but it's
also the part that controls risk-taking
they used to say yeah it fully matures
somewhere around 18 to 20 years old and
now we know most people don't material
about 28 to 30 years old
so what's hasn't really men that don't
don't men reach that level of maturity a
little later a little bit the women had
a little behind but in in terms of the
SOG leaders most of them had not
definitely had not matured and I don't
mean you dated the person was immature
and he's telling that part of the brain
that controls risk-taking so you're
young you think you're bulletproof you
think you can do anything you think
you're going to live forever man this is
a cool thing to do there's a SOG mission
so I think there's something there I
just haven't hey time to explore it well
there's something there might be that
the guys that are 30 years older like
I'm not doing it like the guy that told
you don't volunteer for SOG because
they're saying yeah the survivability is
not high I've got a good I'm not gonna
do it
yeah but the young kids are all right
they're all in yeah how old was bars
well how old were you at this point
barge will barge well I was about four
or five months older than Blairsville
how old were you mm-hmm when Bardwell
came along since 1969 you're 20 to 22 at
46 yes yeah I just become 22 which I
didn't think I would make and I thought
for sure I won't seize 20 20 30 because
I mean we've obviously skipped over a
lot of yeah stuff here we're used a lot
of cat lives but yeah I mean we were
just a few months apart and turn
well every single one of these
operations just about you're gonna use a
certain number or few outlives did you
ever go on an operation where you didn't
get contacted by the enemy
no if you if he count the gas mm-hmm
then no we might contact hundred percent
you're gonna get into contact with the
enemy
all right what was Operation Shiloh all
about and is this where is this why you
left RT Michigan yeah okay so you called
away from RT Michigan they need somebody
to do operation silent what was that all
Mack be SOG and somebody higher up
he decided that they needed to stop the
influx of supplies and and troops coming
down from the north and it was a place
called the media pass big deep valley
but there was a point where really
narrow it up and the banks were really
steep and high and you know so it they
had to funnel through that pass with
their trucks and people and whatever to
come on down into the south and you know
you send a forward air controller out
there I mean they see it so they they
pull off and they hide because they know
that forward air controller has a bunch
of elf fours over here in orbit just
waiting on him to find a target and
they're going to come in so they
somebody came up with the idea what if
we put a team out there
up on the ridge of on the crest of that
valley looking down and and they'll be
able to see far enough that when they're
coming they can call and say okay
they're on their way scrambling you know
get to elf or out here and they all four
can be on I'm like a chicken on a gene
Berg and just eat them up you know so
they decided let's do this mission will
sneak people sneak a team out here
put them on a ridge but I'm set up there
and and just interdict this place like
crazy
but it has to be a super team has to be
officer led has to all the Americans
have to be approved by by name by the
President to do this because of where it
is and what they're going to do so they
they needed somebody a 1-0 officer who
could take over a team that we had there
and you know lead it and they put me on
it I wasn't happy about leaving Michigan
but I thought wow this sounds cool until
I learned more about what they were
going to do and I went on a visual recon
that went out and rode with the forward
air controller why he was putting in air
strikes with without fours and I'm
looking at this place and I'm thinking
there's got to be somebody up here
there's not a high ground they're not
leaving this place undefended yeah and
when I brought that up they said no if
there's nobody there
they we never receive any far from that
area and I said if you don't want people
to know you're there you don't shoot at
them so there's some I'm sure there's
somebody there and anyway so I I had
some disagreements with the people down
in Saigon about that and I had to go
back and forth on a lot of briefings
about the mission but and we took the
other team there I took the team and we
trained and we'd go to mucky mountain
and we practice all the staff and our
surveillance techniques and we had
star-like scopes we had long-range
lenses on our cameras and all the
state-of-the-art binoculars we had a
plan that said and I thought it was
funny that we gonna drop parachutes out
in an area over away from there with
blocks of ice in them so the parachutes
will open just saying hang in the trees
the ice a mill so when the when the NVA
go over there you know they'll think we
parachuted some people then and they
moved out because they won't see anybody
I'm saying they're not stupid anyway so
for four weeks we get ready to go do
this thing and then finally somebody
listened and said no call it off we're
not going to do it and he'll talk to you
and one of your podcast about where he
had this special mission that he had to
have an officer with him yeah
later on after I left it came back up
again he decided to do it and they put
an officer with his team and said you
guys are going to do it and they were
out on the helipad with the rotors
turning and when the mission got called
off because they discovered there were a
bunch of people there and if they had
put either one of those teams in and
when we lost how about dick meadows now
legend now this is all he's alleged at
this time oh yeah yeah I mean everybody
already knew Meadows had been he got to
the point where he'd done all this
super-secret of stuff and they said okay
we're gonna give you a choice you can we
can promote you to sergeant major or we
can promote you to captain which one do
you want and he worked out a deal that
says if you promote me to captain then I
get to state you can't you can't force
me out I get to stay in until I can
retire you know as an also whatever rank
I get to yeah so anyway so he's the this
is I don't know if this is the army or
if it's just Vietnam I think it's a
little bit of both that kind of thing
just doesn't happen anymore where they
take a guy like that go hey we're gonna
either promote you to the senior
enlisted side or make you a captain
which one do you want yeah that's epic
yeah medicine was an epic
yeah I mean so you know I came back from
a mission and I was told that we got a
new company commander and he wants to
see you as soon as you get cleaned up so
I got in to see him that night it was
probably 2200 and actually he was the
quarters were it was a Quonset hut with
the wall I was on one side of he he was
on the other side I go over and report
to him and you know he told me good job
and all this stuff I've been looking at
your record and he said effective right
now you're the Recon company XO
but I don't want to go out of team and
he said you can keep a team I don't care
about that but you the XO and you're
gonna help me and he said to start with
tomorrow morning we're gonna have a
meeting with all the Americans in recon
company one at a time because I've been
going through the records and I think
the some of them's beret has gotten a
little too heavy for him and we're gonna
send them back to the Train tomorrow
they don't need to be in sauk they can
go play with Special Forces but they're
not going to be in SOG what do you mean
he said there are people here who were
not going out on missions very often and
going out on missions and every time
they get shot off the LZ they never
actually complete a mission so you know
those people need to go somewhere else
and we need to replace them and Metis is
a hard dude I'm hard and you can tell
when he's talking to you he is this
serious a heart attack
so he said here take the stack of files
with you go through them tonight
tomorrow 700 you know they're gonna
start coming in you know the Recon
orderly room and
I'm talking you and I gonna have a talk
with so you tell me which one you think
you need to go home
so we met him in there the next morning
and you know I'm looking at the list
that he's the stack he's got the plants
that stand back I said we're not gonna
have anybody left and he said I don't
care if we have to you and I will lead
all the missions you know in my heart's
not beating at this point because I'm
hearing how serious he is in his fours
he said we'll do long yes sir we're
gonna be kind of busy but anyway you
ain't gonna set him a whole home but he
he sent a lot of people backed in the
train that day put him he'd stolen you
helicopters leaving this afternoon
beyond it and he started shuttling
people back down there you know if you
had been you know dragging your feet
finding where he's not digging on
missions you were sick you're you were
whatever and you get shot off the LZ I
mean he looked at you know over the
period of time you had been there how
many missions had you been on how many
times have you been in contact how many
days have you been on the ground and all
the kind of stuff and you know he had
his own little equation and you know
these people needed to find something
else to do I mean he was hard in
big-time Ranger special-ops mindset and
he started looking around right away I
said things here we got to clean up we
should have a nice isolation area when a
team gets a mission you go into
isolation that's the way it's done
Special Forces that's the doctrine and
we're not doing it why would we not do
that here a lot of things like the
training you know he don't mean list the
next morning he said to you meet me down
on the beach the next you know tomorrow
on the beach puts us right outside the
concertina so I made him down there and
he said we're gonna go for a little run
you know considerably older than me at
that point so we take off down the beach
at about a seven-minute pace and I'm
thinking of homing count lion would been
running I mean I'm starting to you know
suck a little wind in here and this
Joker's not slowing down so when we get
about the two-mile point you know I
thought I said sir I'm gonna I'm gonna
go ahead and turn around here and go
back and take care of some things you do
that lieutenant I'm going to keep
running and he kept going and I'd look
back at once a wild he disappeared out
of sight down the beach and he's by
himself and he's unarmed and you know
later on he came back I mean physical
fitness was a big thing for him you keep
your body sharp you'll keep you mind
sharp and you know we started to having
PT in the mornings for the teams that
were not out in the field things like
that you made a lot of changes how did
that affect the attitude around the camp
thanks to you after his house cleaning
at the beginning everybody else's yes
sir whatever you want I mean we need to
do those stuff when we need to do it
right and you know he was out there I
mean everybody knew I mean he's the guy
that would say you've been out twice to
get a prisoner I'm going with you this
time and show you how to get one and
he's going and get one and bring it back
I mean whatever the mission was he'd
good to it and then say now I want the
rest of you do it that way whatever you
say so he said you can keep a team but
here's how we're going to start we've
got a group coming over the first group
in Okinawa we're sending people over
temporary duty had sent four teams of
Americans over and he said I want you to
train them that when they get here you
get with them and their teams and you
put them through some training on how to
run these operations and what to do
and then I want you to go out with them
with each team you take them out you
walk right alongside you know the one
zero I guess we call that skin in the
game yeah we're gonna trade up and then
you're gonna go with them yeah and you
know when you get a team that you think
is ready to go you tell me will sign a
mission to them and you take the next
team he's the snakebite teams it's all
started so you know I was going out on a
regular basis with these guys you know
particularly once I got them trained and
you know we were going into the Marine
Force Recon area of operations they
would put their teams out there within
two or three days you know they get run
out and we were going out and we're the
objective is at stage seven days we you
know we'd eventually make contact
sometimes we make contact before that
but it was a live fire and she backed
target kind of certification
so can you lead her team out against
real bad guys and and get shot at and do
it right and then I give them the check
mark they then they get a SOG mission so
those are the elephant Valley operations
yeah is that what those are so you had
an AO that was a little bit calmer it
was a little bit closer
well had some real bad guys this is just
like the ultimate in training operations
because it's actually real yeah the
target shoot by I mean and we had
several of them wounded you know from
going on those emissions but you know
they always did a great job I mean when
they were there they did a great job so
he kept me busy with that but so I was
technically still going out with teams I
wasn't happy about it I said I'm real
solid machine I don't
it does even count as your sovereigns no
just those are just day-to-day stuff you
go do
you know trying to kill while you're
doing it yeah you just can't either and
you know ironically enough that was very
similar to what it was like you know
when I came home and went to the Ranger
Department became a ranger instructor
that's what I did I was walking along
you know with a team of Ranger students
grading and evaluating the patrol
leaders so he said the targets in sheep
back so that's a little bit of a
difference yeah and then when did you
take over RT Virginia was that your next
it was at your next one zero yeah we
finished with the snake bites and he
said okay I got one more mission for you
before you get your real team back again
and he said we've got a team that we
want to convert over to Vietnamese led
team so it's going to be a team that's
going to operate with no Americans on it
we've got Vietnamese army captain that's
coming in here so he'll be the team
leader and we've got RT Virginia who
hasn't nobody right now and so I want
you to train them with him and then you
can you know take him out on a mission
and make sure he does okay and if he
does okay then you know he will take
over the team and he'll they all start
getting you know SOG missions so as soon
as I got with the team they were saying
no no we don't want Vietnamese captain I
don't know there was just something
about them we bonded very quickly and
then they started saying we want you I
said it can't be me it's got to be this
guy so we're gonna go train and and they
were good and I liked them we got along
well but they did not like the captain
in the end and meadow said okay you take
the team you know you spent all this
time with him you take him and go with
him and then what were those missions
then you started doing it Zog my
selections yeah because they were good
and how many times did you go out with
with Artie Virginia a bunch I know I
have to go and count him now but yeah I
mean that was the last team you know
that I was one zero and so these
missions are the same you know you're
going deep in enemy territory across the
fence as tilt says inserting and trying
to do recon trying to find intelligence
trying to plant sensors and trying to
avoid hundreds if not thousands of and
MVA and sometimes sometimes you went out
looking for a large unit that was the
mission you go find them and once you
find him dan you've got them located
though you bring the world
I mean you introduce them to you know
what we call later chalk and all I mean
you bring all this stuff home because
they can't get away once you know where
they are
so those some of those were just
straight-up Patrol to contact you're
gonna go in there they're gonna patrol
till you find some enemy and then you're
gonna call the fighter you go do that
and I think we we I had an in-country
mission with Virginia but I think the
first outer country was what we
sometimes called a suicide mission we
put in two teams
once we got on the ground we'd separate
for you to be called in the suicide
mission is a real statement about base
hello so we would separate this should
be called the guaranteed death mission
but okay we'll go with it suicide
mission and and one team would be the
the real team that was going to stay out
there
the suicide team would be the one that
was going to go make contact as soon as
possible go find them
pounce on them do as much damage as you
could bring in the world get extracted
and go away but the other teams still
out there and nobody knows that they're
out there now they think
you know that was who got extracted with
so you know it was again so we went out
and you know sure enough it didn't take
us long to to find you know a patina or
so of people and you know so we're
online and we opened fire on them I mean
we would normally just start out like
that but I could see him and you know I
started shooting at him they started
shooting back and it was funny that what
happened we were online and as soon as
all the the bullets started coming back
it was sweep they were all right here
with me and I'm what are you doing and I
said spread out you can't be here with
me I mean you know one be forty take us
all out and that's you know so I had to
smoke them a little bit and tell me
spread back out dispersion is what we
call that and we'd also say don't bunch
up yeah and I would think about the
psychology of what makes people bunch up
like that and part of it I think is just
fear and like you want to be next to
someone else you want to have your buddy
and so as soon as a bullets start flying
it's like I'm gonna get next to you
because we'll be together and I feel
better when we were together and the
other thing I think it's just
communication people want to hear what's
happening people want to know what's
happening and so they figure well the
boss is right there I'll go get with the
boss that I'll know what's happening and
then that's whatever everyone else on
the team thinks the next thing you know
you're too close yeah they knew I had
the radio so were you the suicide team
were you the assault team and that
someone else was there were suicide team
you know so we we hammered that group
which grew once we started hitting them
you know we just kept bringing in enough
airpower to eventually we suppressed it
enough that you know we could get
extracted but so that was but we'd
already we had been in contact once
before the end country mission but yeah
I mean yeah that was a little issue but
we got that resolved you maintain
dispersion and falling whatever their
immediate action drill was but they were
a good team I mean
they they reacted normally very well
under fire and were those were those
Vietnamese Vietnamese yeah so with that
you wrap up with RT Virginia and you get
some R&R and you actually have a
document that you gave me about about
this R&R in Oran or if you don't know
his rest and recuperation and we're
actually going to cover that on the next
podcast so thanks for coming on and
we'll people will fill these people in
on this insane operation that is titled
rest and recuperation so thanks for
coming out thank you for having me all
right on to the next one thank you and
with that mr. dick Thompson has left the
building and once again it is an honor
to be able to sit down with such
incredible men and do have the
opportunity to hear and to preserve
their stories and their lessons and it's
actually crazy for me to be sitting here
and and to have this opportunity and to
be able to share it with anybody that
wants to hear it
anybody that wants to learn so I am very
thankful for this opportunity and one of
the things that allows us to do what
we're doing here is you because by
listening you can take these lessons and
apply them to your life and make
yourself better and if you want to help
us while you make yourself better and it
seems like it would be a good thing to
me okay we could you can help us help
you help us help you
you know what movie that's wrong yes I
do what see feel like you know know
where he's from I do I just recalled it
lay it on me Jerry Maguire interesting
doesn't seem like the type of movie that
you'd watch oh yeah I guess it doesn't
really seem but maybe it was just a
movie that was so popular that at some
point watched it on the create gotcha
cool well help me help you help me help
you a little bit more dramatic
unless yes help yourself that's kind of
the real deal right so what are we doing
to help ourselves Jiu Jitsu anti-stress
activity I was in the locker room good
point
not necessarily changing in the locker
but I'm talking to one of my many
friends in a locker room and when you
think about it jujitsu is like the most
efficient one and off efficient work but
it's like it's exercise competition
friendly and how should I say what do
you call aggressive aggressive but like
what's like beneficial competition you
know how there's like unhealthy hell
we'll just say hello competition
exercise healthy competition
so there's social element to it these
are all things that you get out of it
therapy physical and mental by the way
and stress relief stress which we didn't
really hit it on this initial podcast
but dr. Henry Thompson also known as
dick Thompson who we just spent time
with his book is called the stress
effect and it talks about stress and I
concur that Jiu Jitsu is a stress
reliever yeah big-time yeah it's kind of
like um like you get small levels of
stress in jujitsu to the point where it
doesn't feel like stress button
technically it's stress
just like exercise you know like the
stress is your muscle yeah exactly right
so yeah so it that's I think that's sort
of how it works mentally physically you
know a little bit of stress on there and
then boom the result of that stress is
no stress yeah way it goes you know when
we're doing you just do what do we need
ease and rash guards that's the uniform
for lack of a better term what kind of
gives beginning one hundred percent or
hundred percent merging these hundred
percent yeah making the best geese in
the world
yeah factually made in American America
yeah from American from American
ingredients ingredients
the masked peace that is the key yeah
yeah everything else to also you know
shirts and jackets and joggers jeans I
saw you in jeans for the first time I
think ever when I don't know it was like
we were going somewhere oh yeah
Washington representing big time yeah I
look good I felt like I look good yeah
I'm not gonna ask your opinion on that
matter nonetheless yes I was
representing big time um with my
American geez American denim you're from
dirty shirt as they say on the last
jeans joggers supplements joint warfare
I'm back on discipline that's like two
weeks or anything like and I don't they
don't you you know you sometimes you
slip off for whatever reason you run out
whatever yeah subscription yeah I'm not
even get a subscription yeah so you can
get a subscription that way you don't
run out you can go on to origin main
dot-com and you can subscribe so that
every whatever monthly you get your you
get your resupply you know and that way
you don't fall off the train yeah and
you save money to cheaper oh yeah and
that's like there's certain things in
life that are like that where like you
eat them or use them or whatever like
every day and to go on especially if
they say money to go on those little
subscription it's just it's a that will
improve your efficiency in your life one
less thing you have to think about oh
yeah and it just comes and don't like
that disparaging notes just not
disparaging it's just despair yeah that
despair that moment you know
it's gonna be three days yeah even if I
FedEx it you know they gotta get the
order yam no subscribe exactly right so
what supplements to it weren't fair
krill oil these are for your joints and
general health really curcumin that's
general health right there also
discipline and discipline go finally I
got the jack dock Jack savage savage
that's Dakota Myers signature signature
signature drink I like it it's comin
done a side-by-side comparison you know
as far as like which one I prefer but it
I won't be surprised if that is my
favorite one
Oh your new favorite yes because your
old favorite was Tropic Thunder topic
thunder yes the lemon lime was kind of
too basic to be my favorites to find so
great that's weird because the basic one
that you're over there disparaging no no
no no lemon line is my favorite at this
time well you're a simple person you
know I get it in a good way my wife kind
of curiously asked me she was like how
many of these can I drink a day because
it turns out my wife is really into
their disappoint couple yeah so yeah so
anyways I'm thinking four cans is around
the limit per day yeah I'll be drinking
I've done three and I'm great yeah nope
you know holic cuz like if you drink
even like a coffee scenario where you
did you get to a point where you drink
too many coffees and you're like I don't
feel good anymore you're weird or offer
what a fidgety you know all these little
symptoms you know I've never actually
taken a complete sip of coffee in my
whole life
no kidding yeah I don't like the smell
of it which means I don't like I don't
even have people go well haven't you
ever tasted it I'm like well I'm I
suppose at some point I'm guessing I put
a little sip into my mouth but even the
smell alone I smelled it was like a no
like this yeah what about um coffee like
flavored like it don't like coffee ice
cream but I did yes okay but even then
you know sometimes there'll be some kind
of special treat like some kind of a
weight this tiramisu you know what
tiramisu is doesn't that have some
coffee flavor in it
okay well it seems to to me but I don't
like it no no that's the only one
tara misu yeah that's that one dessert
that's it's sort of like takes some
skill to make and if it's on the menu at
a really nice restaurant sometimes I'll
have a little scenario happen but I get
my tiramisu
partially and this is sort of a
rationalization partially because well
what I tell myself is like well you know
I I kind of need to see what it tastes
like because there's there's some
tiramisu one of the best things I've
ever tasted in my life was Tara masu it
was in Canada at this little Jeremy
Stephens sister got done cutting weight
we went to this out we went to the yeah
weighed in and we went to this Italian
place homemade Italian place and the guy
fed us so much food it was just I was
sick how much food we ate and then he
goes I'm making you my term stern I said
yeah no no my guys I'm making it for you
you know I'm just I'm gonna do it you
just be quiet
so it took like 40 minutes mm-hmm he
like made it yeah he brings out you know
you know once you've eaten a lot you
still think you can eat more but then
after like 15 minutes are like no I
can't so he was like 40 minutes so now
I'm just thinking myself I cannot eat
anymore
yeah he brings out this tara misu newzik
and he I forget what kind of actually
had but he had an accent it was either
French or Italian I think it was French
but you know he just put it in front of
me and I ate I took a bite and it was
the it was definitely one of the best
things I've ever had dang that's saying
a lot
because it's one thing it's like you're
hungry and the first time you had it has
an impression and imprinted in your
brain but you're like basically the
worst conditions to have that that mean
it's so good oh yeah dang because
everything else was good too so anyways
maybe a medium need to make a Tara
masoom Molk as if that's even a thing
but wait what is - is there a thermos
you like a flavor I don't know and I got
is research I know I got to do research
so you know what that means got eats of
North Terrace
so speaking of MalK you can get milk
that's protein it's another dessert
which is as good as tara misu sure it's
as good as 94% of tiramisu c-couldn't
there's only 6% of Tara mysteries that
are mind blowing the rest of them you
know they're okay is it because of the
coffee I have no idea I mean I went any
idea what's in tiramisu I don't know
what it is but it tastes good in 6%
situations
Mulk 100% please good how this last
night speaking milk I ran out of milk
so do I just be a savage and put water
in it because it wasn't that serious
keep in mind and this is literally true
ahead I was eating steak rice broccoli
and those sort of it yeah what did you
eat or whatever yeah I need a little
something right girl is but here's the
thing when you eating steak rice
broccoli
you don't need additional protein
necessarily unless the steak is small I
get it but at that moment you don't
necessarily need it I just wanted it but
I'm out of milk so you see my conundrum
right here is it kind of not worth it
kind of situation but I found some you
know the one in the can the operated
milk you know that thing you ever tasted
yeah yeah Brett doesn't taste good yeah
it tastes pretty wack actually but you
put it in the milk it makes it like more
oh it was good
it was surprising really good yes it was
like it was like the same deal that
dessert a little bit extra creamy I put
some peanut butter in it too it was a
dark chocolate one
so yes mall you are correct 100 B little
I'll stop going to be little the other
day you know I said you know I've only
actually had the darkness Mulk
a couple times you have yes and he said
you gotta try it again it's really good
and so I went home and I was like okay
I'm gonna have I'm gonna have the dark
darkness it's good that's my main jam
right now Oh darkness you yeah so all
I've kind of disparaged that flavor a
bit oh yeah well you know everything
else is so great and then there's
chocolate the darkness now I'm sort of
thinking I underestimated the quality
and the taste we have the darkness
okay so you get milk you can also get
strawberry milk and chocolate milk for
your kids war your kid milk so that
they're healthy for the strawberry one
I'm not saying do this mm-hmm but do
this just try it
how about this just try it add a half a
banana in it just do that my port back
did I tell you my daughter the other day
she sent me she's in college
and she sent me a snapchat yeah sure
yeah yeah all good yeah well yeah that's
that's closed scenario with the fam oh
closed circuit I got you and anyways cuz
she's a 18 year old girl she sent me a
snap of her of her shake and it said it
said you could you could just know
exactly what it said it said literally a
peanut butter chocolate milkshake that
was the text written and then she called
me because I don't really check snap
that often of course I don't think I've
got it live for notifications but then
she said you know she sent me a text
check your snap and I said why what is
everything okay you know really just
made the best it's literally so anyways
I think it's complete hilarity not 99%
100% hilarity how witnessing second hand
by the way you navigate your way through
the current trends of eighteen-year-old
snapchat lingo scenarios that's very
funny yeah and I'm sure I'm not the only
one
yeah also Joe Kuwaiti let's not forget
about the junk away you know you once
you kind of deadly fall that weight or
whatever we tend to forget where you
know how you got there so let's just not
forget that yeah and plus winter is here
kind of sure seto fall ya fallish but
what that means is warm drinks there's
one do others to drinks to drink warm
milk warm sure like chocolate mole where
your kid milk is better warm interesting
yeah and I did that I
a while ago right when the work he came
out it's better one or you can drink it
jakka white tea warm it's good if you
haven't been yes you can get all these
amazing
I shouldn't say amazing amazing is one
of those words that it like it started
off as a joke because people we're
amazing but Bradley you're not amazed by
this just say good or whatever in unless
those jokes oh I'd say it as a joke
mocking or no you're serious yeah you
know how it rolls into your normal lingo
after all it did that anyway these items
to keep you on the path help yourself
help others all that origin me.com it's
Rehana also chuck was this door called
choco store so you go to chuckles TOCOM
what can get their rash guards rash
guards this is like representative of
the path you're on the path you
represent on the kind of like if people
know if you listen and you know you see
somebody representing in the wild right
you know they're on the path 100% oh
yeah
even at the gym I'll see people yeah
well there's a lot of people wearing the
rack guard here at our gym yes I wanted
this oh yeah and to me that tells me how
to present like you know when uh when I
see somebody that's wearing you know
that's representing big time I just give
them like a little head a little
something yes sir
I need to yeah because it's not it's not
acknowledgement its unification right
yes like I'm with you
yeah we're together oh yeah we're in
this fight oh yeah I feel it two men and
I think that's a common thing you know
like I'm sure Pete could tell you too
like a fuse at the post office or
wherever and he sees like somebody with
the you know there's some orange boots
on or something like this you just kind
of look at him look at the boot to me
like yeah you know yes you know t-shirts
truckers hats beanies hoodies what else
good stuff cows on there we replaced
some stuff yeah it's just go coaster
calm if you like something came in get
something represent good spot
forget about this podcast if you want to
listen to it and when you want to know
when it comes out then you can subscribe
to this podcast wherever you subscribe
to podcasts which is a good call because
echo doesn't think you've subscribed to
it yet
I actually don't think that okay there
you go I think I survive really do you
say it anymore no well you know I think
people subscribe no it's a cool reminder
you just got trapped it's a cool
reminder yes wherever you listen to
podcast yes subscribe if you would if
you want fully also speaking of
subscribing
it's another podcast that people seem to
like mmm called grounded keeps you
grounded kind of jiu jitsu a theme it's
not it's not really a jiu-jitsu thing it
kind is it's just more what exploring
certain elements of life in a little bit
more loose way I guess yeah that's a
good way of talking about it yeah it's
just kind of a little bit more mellow
version if the geo podcast yes just kind
of talk about stuff but when you listen
to it like you it kind of feels like the
feeling right because you have a certain
experience when you listen to pocket the
feeling you get because I listen to it I
don't get feelings for going we it's
kind of like okay a conversation going
on about a certain thing and you kind of
want to chime in more like that's how I
feel you know like like when elicit it's
like a conversations going on kind of
with you it's what it feels like no no
that was my one of my prelim experiences
with it nonetheless called grounded
podcasts same deal on uh you know iTunes
Google Play all that stuff
also the word hit but guess mm-hmm don't
forget about that one though the young
ones and don't forget about that one's
eyes and we have two in the bank I got
one more to prep and we'll get another
three warrior kid podcasts out there so
working it and then don't forget about
the warrior kid soap from Irish Oaks
ranch calm if you're going to support a
warrior kid it's a good way to do it
he's running a business at age 13
no big deal yeah with legitimate
products by the way because it's one
thing again I said this for like you
know how your friend or your neighbor
whoever they give you the soap wrapped
in the little decorative plastics
ribbons you know that soap not really
but well they'll do it from time to time
and they're like hey here's your gift
item you know so it's like cool to him
but yeah you would think but it's not
real so it's real soap technically but
like you use it and you're like bread
this isn't for use this is like a
decorative piece you put on the sink on
the side or something like that
it's like that's what it is this one
shaped like a claymore mine or something
usually it's shaped like a turtle shell
or like a you know raindrop I don't know
a bruised tank typically no less Jacko's
soap the one the eight inmates it's like
good you it's soap so like you use it
you're supposed to use it's not water
it's not a wall hanger it's not a
decorative piece got it's functional as
you say it'll help you also YouTube
channel if you're interested in the
video version of this podcast you know
if you have a smart TV like hanging in
your wall and your gym and your or in
your house whatever your office whatever
you want to play the spot guest boom put
on the youtube version I say that does I
hear that people are doing that I've
seen videos of people doing that means
it's pretty cool plus you can see echoes
videos that he well it's up for debate
whether he goes overboard or not I think
something that's clearly that it has
gone I think they're like like what do
you call borderline pushing the envelope
I see the perfect amount of modulation
with fire explosions sound effects and
gel oh yeah check that out we also got
psychological warfare if you need a
little mental support that's me giving
it to you through your mp3 platform
then there's flipside canvas calm this
is visual support run by my brother
Dakota Meyer who's making graphic art
representation of the path cool stuff
check that out flipside canvas calm okay
we got some books number one the stress
effect look we got two more podcasts
with dick Thompson he wrote a book we'll
cover in the third podcast but it's
called the stress effect if you want to
get ahead you can order it now we've got
it listed on the website why smart
leaders make dumb decisions and what to
do about it the stress effect so check
that out of course we also have
leadership strategy and tactics which is
my new book coming out January 14th I
was flipping through the index it's a
heavily indexed book so that you can
quickly find what you're looking for but
it's pretty cool when you when you are
looking through the index here's some
here's some things communication with
bosses forms of complaints complex
problems compromise condon calmness
comes to countenance tension confidence
construction sites contingency planning
counseling countenance it's got some
it's got some very interesting topics
all about leadership check that one out
then of course there are the warrior kid
books one two and three to get kids on
the path we got Mikey and the Dragons
for the littler kid teach that kid to
overcome fear we have the discipline
equals freedom Field Manual the first
field manual about how to be on the path
if you want to know about workouts
there's a bunch of workouts in there for
you if you want to know about martial
arts there's a bunch about martial arts
in there if you want to know about food
it's in their sleep it's in there all
that stuff's in there and then there is
the thoughts from me and and then
there's extreme ownership and the
dichotomy of leadership these are the
two leadership books that I wrote with
my brother life babban and if you need
help with your leadership you can check
those out
there's also a tional on front this is
our leadership consultancy and what we
do is solve problems through leadership
go to a salon front calm for that if you
want to get some of that training online
check out EF online you don't need
someone from echelon front to show up at
your business to give you the
instruction you can get it from EF
online online training interactive
online training then we have the muster
the next muster is in Sydney Australia
which is happening now this is probably
already done so look at extreme
ownership comm for details of the
forthcoming musters in 2020 and then we
have EF overwatch and EF Legion this is
where we are taking folks from the
military and placing them into civilian
companies that need leadership and if
you want to continue to hear from us
then you can interact with us on the
interwebs and dick Thompson is on
Twitter by the way he is at HP s
underscore CEO and he also has a website
HP sis sys comm that's high performance
systems that's his company so if you
want to check out or you want to
interact with dick Thompson credible
human being check them out and then also
we are on Twitter as well we are an
Instagram and we are on ye olde phase
and boudic echo is at echo Charles and I
am at jackal Wellington thanks once
again to dr. Henry dick Thompson for
sharing his wisdom on this program today
and more important thanks to Colonel
Thompson for his service and sacrifice
to protect freedom and democracy around
the world for his whole career and
thanks to the rest of our military men
and women that are out there today doing
the same for us now and to all the
police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and EMTs and
dispatchers and correction
officers and Border Patrol Secret
Service and all first responders thank
you for protecting us here on the home
front and everyone else out there we all
want to do better everybody wants to be
better everyone talks about becoming
better but I'll tell you right now it
doesn't just happen in fact it will not
happen on its own it will not happen on
its own you have to make it happen you
have to lead yourself you have to make
yourself better by attacking everyday in
spite of whatever challenges you face
every day go out there and get after it
and until next time this is echo and
Jocko out